hello everyone welcome to the february
2021
ask me anything edition of the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
as probably most of you know this ama is
something we do almost every month
i don't do it at the end of december
because i take the holidays off but
every other month 11 times a year
we do something where patrons
that is to say supporters of mindscape
on patreon
can ask me questions they leave
questions in the comments of a post i
put up on patreon
only cost one dollar per episode to be a
patreon supporter
and i try to answer as many of them as i
can and the
patrons are the ones who suggested that
going forward we should make the
answers that is to say the episode
you're listening to right now
public domain so that is what we're
doing so this is available a little
while after the patrons get it
it gets released into the wild and
anyone can listen
uh i noticed that over the past couple
months there have been an
increase in the number of patrons which
is a good thing not going to argue about
that
and also of course we skipped last month
doing the ama so as a result
we got a lot of questions this month i
think ordinarily the number is around
100 and this month it's closer to
175 180 something like that and so
it does become difficult for me to
answer all the questions in a reasonable
period of time
and i really want to do that uh so for
this one i did it you know i just
answered all the questions that i got
i i did try to make the answers a little
shorter
than they usually would be i reigned in
my natural
inclinations just go on a great length
on somewhat tangential topics
so going forward if we continue to grow
and there continue to be more questions
asked in amas
we can contemplate different strategies
for what to do about that
a strategy of just continuing to answer
every question is going to be harder so
for the
people who support on patreon out there
if you want to leave comments
about you know what do you prefer do you
prefer if i just answer some subset of
the questions the first
hundred questions uh the best hundred
questions a random hundred questions
should i answer even fewer questions but
at greater length you know should i pick
the questions i really think allow me to
say interesting things rather than
some of the questions i have to say like
you know no i can't i can't answer that
i don't know the answer to that
these are all possible ways going
forward i mean with the constraint that
i don't want the amas to go on
too much longer than three hours i'm
pretty open to what the strategy should
be
anyway we did get a lot of questions
this month we got some really good
questions
so let's go
peter benham asks being able to ask
questions is a great bonus of being a
patron
and by the way i did not ask peter to
say this is not a setup
he just mentions it right off the bat
but then he says i had a feeling it
would be the case but why
is it so hard to ask a good question and
not sound like an imbecile no matter how
much you think you know about something
um so i'm going to deny the premise of
this question peter i think that in fact
if we read over the questions that
people ask in the amas
they're generally pretty good i don't
think any of them are sort of things
that i would say oh you sound like an
imbecile
some questions are easy to answer some
questions are hard to answer but
the interesting thing is why would you
feel like
you sound like an imbecile and i don't
just mean you i mean why do we
collectively worry about how we sound
when we ask questions
to be fair you know i tell this to my
graduate students and they don't always
like to hear it
but on the one hand for graduate
students you want to tell them
it's part of your job to speak up in
seminars right to ask questions to
participate in the conversation you're a
scientist now you're not just a student
on the other hand they say yes but i
worry that if i ask a dumb question that
everyone will be
judging me and the truth is the honest
response to that
is yes everyone is judging you this is
part of being a student
pardon me a graduate student especially
people are judging you all the time
for what it's worth they don't stop
judging you when you get your phd the
judging of other scientists is just
part of academia as it is right now hard
to imagine getting away from that
um so i get why you would worry that
yeah you're
sounding like an imbecile and it's not
it's not something
that you can dismiss easily but
ultimately you'll be much better off
if you just say you know what if i have
a question and it's a good one
i'm gonna ask it let the chips fall
where they may nicholas walker says are
the answers to dark matter and energy to
be found at the quantum level
um you know the short answer is i don't
know since i don't know what the answers
are
the second shortest answer is i don't
know what it means to be
found at the quantum level you know the
quantum level is the whole universe
everything in the universe is quantum so
in some trivial sense it is
sure probably what you mean is something
like
are there specifically quantum phenomena
that can go into explaining or that are
needed to explain dark matter and dark
energy
for dark matter the answer is probably
no i mean it's very easy to come up with
models of dark matter that fit the data
perfectly well the problem is
there are too many of them and we don't
know which one is right and none of
these models involve
esoteric quantum phenomena in any
central way for dark energy it's harder
to say we have a perfect candidate for
dark energy the cosmological constant
that einstein
mentioned a long time ago uh you could
have a perfectly classical cosmological
constant but there's a big puzzle about
why the value
of the cosmos constant is the value that
it is so
it's possible that the answer to that
puzzle will lie in
some interesting quantum mechanical
phenomena that's absolutely possible and
we just don't know right now since we
don't know what the answer is
john lowensbury says with our current
technology what's the fastest craft we
could build and how long would it
be to take overtake voyager 1. uh i have
no idea you've clearly mistaken me for
someone
who knows something about rockets or
engineering and that is not me
maxim alexandrovich says in the big
picture you point out a correlation
between complexity and entropy
does it work work both ways
mathematically can entropy be decreased
by reducing complexity
well i think it's not quite as simple as
a correlation
what i point out in the big picture is
that complex structures
can arise dynamically as entropy
increases
if things are very very very low entropy
they tend to be simple
there's not a lot of room to be complex
if they're very very very high
entropy they tend to be simple so what
that means is in between in the medium
entropy
regime that's where complexity can arise
but it doesn't necessarily arise it
depends on the dynamical rules
that got you from low entropy to high
entropy so there's no simple
straightforward
correspondence between an amount of
complexity and amount of entropy
robert ruxin rescue says suppose you're
some distance away from a black hole and
you throw an object in it you're
going to see the object close in on the
black hole's event horizon but never
actually pass into the black hole
since from your perspective no object is
falling into the black hole how can we
then say that black holes increase their
size when objects fall into them
so it's actually a bit of a myth that
you never see objects fall into a black
hole
that would be the case in the
idealization
where what you're throwing into the
black hole has no gravity itself
right it is what we call a test particle
when we teach general relativity
but in the real world everything you
would throw in a black hole has some
gravity itself
so when you take that into consideration
what happens is that the event horizon
of the black hole grows a little bit
to swallow up the object that you're
falling into because the combined
gravitational field of the black hole
and the object
is a little bit more than the black hole
itself so it was a bit of a myth
a simple a simplification that works
mathematically but it's not quite what
we see in the real world
to say that you never see things fall
into black holes
doug orlean says what are your thoughts
about lee smullen's book the trouble
with physics
um i haven't thought about that book or
read it in quite a while i had mixed
feelings about it i mean lee is a smart
guy and he has interesting things to say
about quantum gravity
i was disappointed that so much of the
book just
went into attacking string theorists
personally rather than they're attacking
them for their science and i don't mean
you know calling out names and saying
they're bad people
but i mean painting people who do loop
quantum gravity as
brave truth-seekers uh trying to
understand the world at a deep level
and painting string theorists are just
sort of boring
people moving incrementally ahead
without much imagination and if you
think i'm exaggerating then i encourage
you to
check out the book and there's a lot in
there about you know group think and the
basically the picture being painted is
that string theorists just aren't nearly
as clever and creative and independent
as loop quantum gravity people are
i think that is entirely the wrong
attitude to take about that particular
problem
mateo tanaka says are we sure the
universal constants like the speed of
light have been the same value since the
beginning of time
uh no we're not at all sure um people
have been
writing plenty of papers suggesting
alternatives um so far all the data
are compatible with the idea of the
universal constants are the same value
but
they might not be in particular things
like the mass of the electron
probably aren't in the standard model of
particle physics the electron was
massless before the electroweak phase
transition and is
massive now but of course the
electroweak phase transition is so deep
in the early universe that we'll never
observe it directly
deeply amara surya says what are your
ideas on helping undergraduate physics
students develop physical intuition and
problem-solving skills in tandem
oh you know i mean this is a great
question but i don't have any deep
special ideas about that
i think in practice it happens by doing
it right you don't develop intuition by
reading a book on how to develop
physical intuition
it might be a little bit of a help but
you gotta do it yourself right it's like
learning to play the piano
by reading a book telling you how to
play the piano but never actually
playing it
that's not gonna work right it's just
never gonna do it
developing physical intuition solving
problems is a lot like
playing the piano or hitting a baseball
or whatever these are skills
that are in some sense um not
reducible at least in our current way of
thinking to an
algorithm you can just learn and
therefore master
you have to actually physically do it to
learn
john says when a black hole evaporates
is there a point where it no longer has
enough mass to be a black hole
and undergoes a phase change into
something like a neutron star
so no that's um the the black hole does
not need to be very massive you can have
a black hole as small as the planck mass
and i know that from particle physics
perspectives the planck mass
sounds like a huge number right but
when you measure it in grams it's
something like 1 100 000
of a gram a blank mass is not a very big
object so we think
that black holes just evaporate away
staying black holes until they go
below the plank mass and then they just
dissolve into kind of a cloud of
photons and other elementary particles
there's no point at which they act like
a neutron star
patrick hall says as you've mentioned on
the podcast your wife jennifer ollette
is a science writer and
author have you and your wife ever
collaborated on projects together if not
is it something you plan on doing in the
future
we haven't collaborated on writing
projects we did once give a talk
together on black hole firewalls that
was fun
but you know actually our interests in
writing even though we both write about
physics we have different interests
jennifer is much more interested in sort
of large-scale
condensed matter fluid mechanical kinds
of things whereas i'm interested in
you know quantum mechanics cosmology
things like that so
uh we have more overlap than the average
people do but not nearly enough yet
anyway to actually write a project
together but it could be fun if the
right one comes along you never know
jamie tan says does physics allow for
something to appear out of absolutely
nothing
no time and no space another way to ask
this is do laws of physics prohibit such
a thing
well that means short answer again is
who knows we don't know we don't know
what the ultimate laws of physics
are uh i would deny that there's even a
sensible way to talk about
something appearing out of nothing no
time and no space because you can ask
well you know when would that happen
right it doesn't really
make a difference make it make sense
what you can do is the other way around
you can approach it from
the side of the universe that already
exists or the thing that already exists
usually this question is asked in the
context of the universe itself can the
universe itself
appear out of nothing no time and no
space so that's the wrong question to
ask i would say the right question to
ask is
can there be a first moment of time
in the history of the universe can there
be a moment before which there were no
other moments
as far as we know sure the laws of
physics
are perfectly compatible with that but
we don't know for certain because we
don't know what those laws of physics
are
i did write a paper that mentions this
uh problem and talks about in more
detail if you're interested call it why
is there something rather than nothing
so you can check that out jeff b
says how should we conceptualize
particle interactions from the many
worlds
perspective especially since wave
functions are seen as physically real
um i'm not sure what you're asking here
there the
many worlds perspective really doesn't
have anything special to say
about particle interactions uh it's just
the same kind of
particle interactions you get in any
other formulation of quantum mechanics
copenhagen
or bohmian or grw or whatever many
worlds doesn't really change that
picture very much
michael shillingford says what's your
preferred answer to vanit
in wagons i think it's fun in bagan
peter van impe it might be in wagon i
don't know how the americanization
pronunciation is
but in wagons special composition
question um so as far as i understand it
i haven't
thought about it in a long time the
special composition question is just a
question about
at what point when you combine things
together do you have a new thing
when it's kind of an inverse
meteorological question instead of
saying you have a big thing how do you
divide into small things
you have a small thing when do they make
a big thing i don't think there's any
sensible way of thinking there's a once
and for all answer
to this question i think it's entirely
dependent on what kind of thing
it is that you are making and also i
don't think there's any metaphysical
um essence of being a thing that we're
gonna ever put our finger on right it's
just a convenient way of talking
uh you can always imagine being
laplace's demon and understanding the
world perfectly
and then never talking about composite
objects just talking about the
fundamental reality that evolves forward
in time or whatever it does
it's we human beings that have access to
limited information limited time limited
powers of observation and description
we find it useful to talk about
composite objects and so
it's our usefulness that would judge
when
it is sensible to talk about something
being object or not
um and that that usefulness is going to
completely depend on the context you're
talking about you're talking about
galaxies you're talking about
single-celled organisms are you talking
about something much more abstract so
in that sense i guess i don't have a
preferred answer
jeremy payne says can you comment on
superfluid dark matter
theories um i don't know much about them
i did hear one talk by justin corey of
the university of pennsylvania
which was very good actually about
superfluid dark matter it was very
compelling in the sense that if you
believe this particular crazy
model you can explain a lot of things
okay so superfluid dark matter is a dark
matter
kind of particle but it condenses so
it's not just an
individual set of particles or i should
say it's not a set of individual
particles doing their own thing the
particles
interact with each other and form a
superfluid and that actually changes
perhaps their distribution in galaxies
and clusters and interesting ways so i
think it's a very interesting idea
but as far as i could tell from justin's
talk the particle physics models that
make it work
are not yet very compelling maybe we
just haven't thought of the right one
yet
justin bailey says what was it like
going on the colbert report
did he prep you for the questions or
were you reacting in real time so it was
a lot of fun
going on colbert um it's not going to
happen anymore because now he's on a
network he used to be on comedy central
and
the standards are different they don't
want to have five minutes of just him
talking to scientists anymore
um he will talk to scientists but only
if they're doing sort of
crazy visual demonstrations which is not
really my
expertise so uh they want you to succeed
actually um they they think of
scientists and other academics
differently than they think about
politicians
or comedians or or whatever because you
know
they're if when it's a politician on
that show
their goal was a little bit to puncture
the presumption the you know the um
self-regard that a politician typically
has whereas with scientists
they actually want to get the science
out so what i was told was you know you
will be given a chance
to say your piece to actually say the
little bit of science that you want to
have
but it's mostly entertainment so it's
mostly about telling the jokes
so the weird piece of advice that i got
was don't stop talking in other words
when you're on the radio or whatever
when you're doing a tv documentary
you try to keep things short sweet get
to the point do a sound bite
on colbert you're asked to do exactly
the opposite just keep talking until he
interrupts you
because he's trying to think of jokes
right he's not actually an interviewer
trying to get out information from you
um but certainly i'm not giving the
questions ahead of time it was
absolutely all
in real time typically those interviews
were six or seven minutes and they
they edited it down to about five
minutes so a little bit of the more
boring parts
were cut out mtmd murtaugh says
what why is the emergence of space-time
specifically not
like the emergence of a baby bird from
its egg well it's just two different
senses of the word emergence the word
emergence for the baby bird
is literally a process happening over
time
the bird is in the egg the egg begins to
break the bird emerges from it okay
the word emergence in philosophy or
physics is not a process
evolving over time it's a relationship
between two different theoretical
descriptions
that can both be simultaneously true
when you say that
there's a theory of the air in the room
in terms of atoms and molecules
and there's a different theory of the
air in the room in terms of a fluid
and you say that fluid or gas
description is emergent
it's not like there is some temporal
process that takes it from being atoms
and molecules to fluid
both are always true at the same time
joshua hillerup says why does black hole
evaporation seem to be
so much more accepted as true in physics
compared to other theories that aren't
confirmed by experiment
well it's not a hundred percent accepted
because because it hasn't been confirmed
by experiment
but it is a prediction of theories that
are pretty well confirmed by
experiment namely classical general
relativity and
quantum field theory so generally it's
not like a completely new
theory that we're starting with when we
talk about black hole evaporation we're
applying ideas from
theories that have been confirmed by
experiment to new situations that we
haven't specifically
observed and generally there i think
that if you do the calculations
correctly
your attitude should be since the
theories
seem to be good i should accept the
prediction of those theories until i
have some reason
not to of course you don't accept it 100
but you put a high credence on it until
you have evidence otherwise
bill warner says what is the volume of a
black hole with respect to the event
horizon is a black hole most like a
solid liquid or gas
well it's a very hard question to answer
not because it's technically difficult
but because
what do you mean by volume you can uh
we talk about the volume inside but
remember a black hole is a region of
space time
not just a region of space and so
because its general relativity and space
time is curved
you have to decide how to slice the
space time
inside the black hole to calculate the
volume volume is a three-dimensional
concept
not a four-dimensional concept and the
right way to slice the volume
inside is not at all obvious so it's
just a hard question to answer
having said that what you would call the
density
of a black hole depends completely on
its size and the density basically goes
down as the black hole goes up
so if it's a very small black hole the
density is really really high
if it's a very big black hole the
density is relatively low so it can be
whatever you want
depending on the kind of black hole
you're thinking about
scott says in quantum field theory is it
preferable to think of a particle and
its anti-particle
as arising from the same field that has
an extra degree of freedom
or do you think of a particle and
antiparticles arising from different
fields
well a little bit this is up to you and
it depends on what you count as
a field okay i mean think about it's not
a directly
applicable example but think about the
electromagnetic field right we have the
electric field and we have the magnetic
field and each of those have three
components because they're
three-dimensional vectors
or you can say well they arise from a
single four-dimensional field
the vector potential and the different
components of the field are all doing
something so
in that case if you have a vector a
four-dimensional vector field
do you say that's one field with four
components or do you say it's four
different fields that group together
to make a four-dimensional field that's
going to be important to the answer to
your question so
generally the particle and antiparticle
for something like an electron
can be grouped together in one big field
this is a fermionic field
paul durock told us how to talk about
these fields in terms of what are known
as derox spinners
and the dirac spinner involves both the
particles and the anti-particles
but you could also choose if you wanted
to to divide all those components up
into
a spin left electron a spin right
electron a spin left positron and a spin
right positron if you wanted to do that
patrick henderson says have you ever
encountered a campaign to systematically
misrepresent your views
in order to lend credibility to fringe
or conspiratorial ideas
i think not exactly i've never been
completely horn swaggled like that or
or misused like that but you know close
in some ways you know look i've said
enough things online and enough people
have read things i've said online
that all the time i hear people on
twitter
or blogs or whatever on reddit claiming
that i believe something that i
certainly don't believe
right and there's no citation there's no
reference there's no quote or anything
like that and
it's impossible to stamp out all of it
all you can say is sort of roll your
eyes and go i wish people would
read what i wrote rather than just
making things up
but that's not systematic right um only
once was i on a tv show
where i felt like i was clearly being
trapped or lied to
there was a show about um supposed to be
about extreme
crazy phenomena right so uh it was
it was basically supposed to be the real
world version of mulder and scully in
the x-files you know
investigating interesting ideas but i
wasn't told that what i was told was
they were doing an episode on quantum
teleportation and they wanted me to
talk a little bit about quantum
teleportation and i said well
i'm nowhere near the world's biggest
expert on quantum teleportation
and they said that's okay you can just
talk about quantum mechanics more
generally
and then i get on the show to be
interviewed by the um
uh two hosts and it became quickly clear
that they had no idea what quantum
teleportation is or even heard of it
they had an idea that the u.s government
had
teleportation technology and was using
it to shuffle
astronauts back and forth to mars and
this was a big cover-up on the part of
the government
this was entirely different than what i
was told the
interview would be about and so i
literally took off my microphone and
walked away
in the middle of it i'd never done that
before never done that since these days
i do a lot more homework
before i agreed to be interviewed by
somebody jacob arkhan says
are you familiar with the recent
watchmen hbo adaptation
if so what do you think about his
portrayal of eternalism and attempt at a
place's demon-esque
character um you know i i did see the
watchman was great i
highly recommend it if no one has seen
if anyone has not seen it
um i don't specifically remember having
deep
thoughts about dr manhattan or any other
you know
questions about eternalism in that
particular adaptation look it is
um often the case there's many different
stories
um where there's a character in sort of
a fantasy or science fiction scenario
which is
supposed to know everything both about
the past the present and the future
right this is a trope
and it's never done accurately because
they always change their mind or they
you know decide not to do something that
they were going to do you know they're
constantly violating the self-imposed
idea
that they actually know with
deterministic certainty what's going to
happen in the past present and future
so i would rather they just not have
characters like that that would be my
particular
preference michael daniels says if the
cosmos used to be dense
and closed and subsequently expanded
with deceleration to flat space with
omega of one
must we not be flying headlong into
pringle land by which he means
negative curvature so no and the answer
is because
we have not gone from a closed universe
to a flat universe that does not happen
that never happens
in robertson walker cosmology and
robertson walker cosmology which is sort
of
just the cosmology of general relativity
where space is taken to be
similar on all on all places right so
homogeneous and isotropic there are
three choices
for what the geometry of space can be it
can be positively curved like a
three-dimensional sphere
it can be flat like three-dimensional
flat space or it can be negatively
curved like a pringle
or a saddle but it is a feature of the
equations that you
never undergo a transition from one of
those to the other
so when people say you have a curved
universe
positively curved or negatively curved
or whatever which because of inflation
or because of other dynamics in the
early universe
becomes flat what they mean is it
becomes flatter
than it was it never becomes perfectly
flat a closed universe which is a sphere
has a compact topology and it's never
going to change into a non-compact
apology of a flat universe
so we're never going to become
negatively curved if we're not already
david h says when the universe splits
allah everett
is the split instantaneous across the
whole pre-existing universe or does it
propagate at the speed of light
so the nice answer is it's up to you and
this goes exactly back to what we were
talking about about laplace's demon
earlier
the branching of the wave function of
the universe into separate worlds
is not part of the fundamental theory
the fundamental theory is
there's a wave function that evolves
according to the schrodinger equation
that's the entire theory
the splitting into worlds is something
that we human beings do for our
convenience
so the right way to ask this question is
is it more convenient
to imagine the world splitting all at
once across all of space
or propagating at the speed of light and
for that
it's completely dependent on what your
purpose
is right i actually tend to think of it
as simpler just to imagine the universe
splitting
all at once uh pre-existing
simultaneously across the whole
pre-existing universe
that bothers some people because they
say well that's not compatible with
special relativity
which says that signals can't travel
faster than the speed of light but
there's no
signal traveling faster than the speed
of light it's just our description
is traveling faster than the speed of
light and that's perfectly okay
a slightly more sophisticated worry is
two different observers
moving in two different velocities two
different lorenz frames
would describe the split of the universe
differently and the response to that is
just
yeah sure they would who cares they
would still end up agreeing on every
single prediction for every single
observable thing
so that kind of observer dependence of
description doesn't really bother me
david maxwell says could dark matter be
the result of theoretical white holes
that the process involved makes what
comes out invisible as normal matter
energy but it still affects gravity
um so probably not uh you know white
holes probably don't exist white holes
are kind of like black holes but run
backward in time which would violate the
second law of thermodynamics which is
generally why we
don't think that white holes exist and
also if they did exist
and something came out of them there's
zero reason to think it would be
invisible or anything like that it'll be
ordinary photons and particles
so uh you're just making more particles
you're just
you just have a very fancy way of
filling the universe with particles so
why not just put particles in it and ask
about that
paul hardy says i saw a video discussing
the janus point and
that you did work on it can you briefly
explain what the janus point is
uh yeah so the janus point is a term
coined
by julian barber who is a gravitational
physicist
and julian and his colleagues have this
theory of cosmology according to which
entropy can grow both toward the future
and in the extreme past so there's some
middle point some janus point where
entropy was lowest
and it grows in both directions away
from that point
and this of course is an idea that i had
quite a while ago in 2004
jenny chen and i published a paper with
exactly that kind of idea
the specific example implementation we
used of that idea was very different
so you know the julian barber's paper is
completely separate from ours
but the idea that there is a
moment in the history of the universe
when entropy is minimum
and it increases in both directions
around that uh dates back to our paper
in 2004. disconjazz
says if you had to redo your entire
education over and for some reason were
precluded
from studying any discipline of physics
proper what branch of academia would you
choose
that's a good question there's so many
good choices you know philosophy would
be the obvious one
but i think that what actually happened
to me becoming a physicist first and
then
moving more into philosophy afterward
was the better way to go
because there's more parts of philosophy
that i am not that interested in
than there are physics and i might have
gotten very frustrated if i didn't
realize early in my philosophy education
that there were the good parts
that i really really like that are
really foundations of physics really
just doing physics but in a philosophy
department honestly that's the kind of
part that i like
but otherwise i probably could have been
very happy studying uh theoretical
computer science or artificial
intelligence or complex systems
things that i'm already kind of
interested in um a little bit
now so i'm trying now that i'm old and
i'm not doing my education all over i'm
still trying to learn about those
different
subjects jeremiah m says what are your
personal
top 10 most interesting unanswered
questions in physics
uh so i don't have a personal top ten
sorry i don't have a list hanging around
this this is secretly ten questions and
the rules of the ama are
you're only allowed to ask one so i'll
mention a couple but they're obvious
right i want to know
um what is the correct formulation of
quantum mechanics right i think i know
that i think it's the everett
interpretation so maybe that's not a top
10 one
i would like to know how to quantize
gravity or how to reconcile quantum
mechanics
with gravity would be a better way of
putting it everyone wants to know that
and i think that's very interesting
i want to know why the cosmological
constant has the size it does
i want to know if quantum field theory
breaks down i want to understand
non-locality in quantum gravity and
things like that
i also want to understand a bunch of
things about complex systems how they
come to be how they evolve
how they are related to the evolution of
entropy over time
so that's nobody else's list of
interesting questions in physics but
those are my personal favorites
frank layman says do you have a
particular stance toward the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics and science as articulated
by vigner
and many philosophers of science and
mathematics since does it keep you up at
night
so no it does not keep me up at night at
all i think i've said this before
maybe not in the amas but i don't think
that there is any unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics in physics
i think that no matter what the laws of
physics had been
we would end up describing them
mathematically even if the laws were
that things happened completely randomly
we would describe that randomness
mathematically right what else could we
do
i think that what is meant by the
unreasonable effectiveness of
mathematics is
something like the actual physical laws
it's not that they're mathematical but
the mathematics is particularly simple
and elegant
there are many ways the laws of physics
could have been messier than they are
they're a little bit messy they're not
as elegant as you could imagine them
being as far as we currently know
but there's many many ways they could
have been much more
uh messy so i don't know about that i'm
not it certainly doesn't keep me up at
night i would like to understand it
better but
since i don't see an immediate path
forward on that
um it doesn't keep me up so the the
questions that keep me up at night are
the ones that are really really
difficult
but yet you can see some kind of
progress right
you can imagine making progress so the
ones where i don't even know how to make
progress are not ones that i care about
too much
brandon sherwood says when you were an
undergraduate did your first physics
classes click with you right away or was
it a slow learning process like it is
for myself
you know i think it's in between like
some things clicked right away but
look learning physics is always hard i
don't know anyone who just takes a whole
bunch of physics classes and says yeah
this is just easy
right um because it's new to you like
unless you're cheating unless you like
study it ahead of time before you take
the class which by the way is great you
should cheat that's a good thing to do
um but i wouldn't be discouraged by the
fact that it's hard or doesn't does not
click right away it's worthwhile because
it's hard
it takes a lot of effort and takes a lot
of training it takes a lot of
patience and the ability to make
mistakes and learn from them
matjaz hosavar says matias sorry
hosafar says in your last solo episode
on democracy you mentioned that it is
not worth to keep contact with people or
even friends that have been rat
that have radically different views and
beliefs about the world reality politics
and is best to part ways in those cases
my question is
did you have such a similar experience
and what
would have to happen and or change a lot
of slashes in this question
what would have to happen and or change
to resolve this and renew slash continue
that relationship
um so it has happened to me and i i not
exactly sure what i said
i never can remember what i said in
previous episodes so i certainly would
not want to go so far as to say
it's not worth it to keep contact with
people who have radically different
views than you do
what i want to say is it can reach a
point
with people who have radically different
views than you where it is not worth
keeping contact with them
in other words there is no obligation on
your part to continue to be friends with
someone
if your world views have diverged so
radically that they are bringing you
more stress and sorrow
than uh pleasure and fun okay there's no
obligation of that
but it's certainly possible to still be
friends with people who do have
radically different views if you're
still enjoying their company
right um so what would
what would be required to fix it you
know you would have to have some
change of someone's point of view either
your point of view or their point of
view i mean this is not
i'm not saying anything very profound
here i think i'm just saying that
it is possible for two people to sort of
become
friends and then then stop being friends
because of differences between them
right i don't think this is anything new
this is not nothing
special about our current moment or
hypercharged or anything like that
when the things that you can't agree on
elevate in their importance to the fact
that they
color every way in which you relate to
that person it is appropriate to move on
and if you can fix that if you can stop
those things you disagree on from either
being that important or being things you
disagree on then you can move forward
that's all it takes
sam barda says why is entropy so
important if by yours and others
definitions it is a measure of how much
we don't know about a system
well uh it's a very useful thing to keep
in mind how much we don't know about a
system because it helps you make
predictions for things like
the fact that entropy increases over
time
is certainly an incredibly useful
feature of the universe
um we lose information that's a real
fact about the universe right
so and that's you may use to make
predictions to do thermodynamics to
design engines to think about cosmology
all of these things
so what we know about the universe is
very very important to
what we can do with it and how we think
about it johnny says from your recent
conversation with avilo that you walk
away thinking that looking for alien
life is a worthwhile use of time and
resources
i would say you know it is worthwhile
but i would do it at a minimum level i
would not i don't think it's a high
priority i think that um i'm convinced
by the argument that says
it would have been easy to find
ourselves living in a universe where
alien life was perfectly obvious and
everywhere and we could find it very
simply
and it's also easy to imagine we live in
a world where we're never going to find
alien life so the sort of the space
available
for it to be there and findable but hard
to find i think is pretty small
but it's huge payoff if you do it it's
usually important so i think that
like many other high-risk high-gain
things you should have a little bit of
your
portfolio devoted to that but not sell
out entirely in that direction
matthew o'connor says you mentioned on
twitter that you're leaving caltech
i'd be interested to know anything you
can share on why what's next your
thought process and what this means for
the quantum mechanics textbook
uh the good news is it means nothing for
the quantum mechanics textbook that had
nothing to do with me being at caltech
you know my job at caltech is not that
of a tenured professor i'm a research
professor which is in some ways an
amazingly good job
you have very low responsibilities and
huge amounts of freedom but you do have
some responsibilities
and you know the research professor job
is perfect for someone
who has a specific kind of research they
want to do
and just does that just stays focused on
that doesn't move around intellectually
into different areas
stays focused on that sort of one kind
of area so i was hired to be
a theoretical particle physicist and
cosmologist and if i
still wanted to do nothing but that
caltech would be a great place for me to
do that
but i want to do other things and so my
job right now is not
a good fit for what i want to do
and you know so i'll be increasing my
uh the time i spent at santa fe working
on complex things
and i might be doing other things we
don't know yet where there's there's
wheels moving in the background but i'll
surely let people know
i will be sure to let people know when i
know myself what's going to actually
happen
hershey silver says on a scale from 1 to
100 what is the likelihood that humans
will find a wormhole
to travel to distant galaxies within the
next 50 years
one if one means not very likely then
it's one
if 100 means very likely and one means
not very likely it's
pretty much one wormholes are
interesting things to think about but
even in the laws of physics as we
currently understand them
you can't keep them open and travel
through them that's just science fiction
when you build a wormhole it collapses
right away
and you just make a black hole you don't
make a shortcut to travel to distant
galaxies
so probably wormholes don't exist
macroscopically so that you can find
them and if they did you couldn't travel
through them anyway
sorry about that shermanflips says
how does the weight assigned to a given
branch of the wavefunction correspond to
the number of microstates that are in
superposition in that branch so it's
you got to be a little bit careful there
basically it is that number but i want
to be careful here because
number of microstates is a slightly
ambiguous
concept in quantum mechanics right if
what you mean is
the number of dimensions of hilbert
space
that correspond to that branch that's
what it means the number of
different directions in hilbert space
that you can add together
in some principled way to make that
particular vector corresponding to that
branch
okay whether you want to call a
dimension of hilbert space a microstate
or not
is up to you um there's another way of
thinking about things if you just have
like a bunch of spins
okay so you have a bunch of
two-dimensional uh hilbert spaces one
for each
spin spin up or spin down but the
dimensionality of the combined hilbert
space
is not two n if you have n spins
it's two to the n right so you don't
have one
dimension of filtered space for each
dimension of the subspaces you
exponentiate them that's why
it depends on what you mean by
microstate but basically that is what
the weight means you're on the right
track
thinking about that sean drew says
the visual representation of electron
wave functions seems to have some
resemblance to the hypothesized dark
matter distribution in solar systems
is there anything to this and are there
actual smart people thinking about this
um so is there anything to this it
depends
uh there is something to it but it's an
incredibly trivial thing
it's just basically that lots of things
in nature
take big puffy spherically symmetric
cloud-like shapes okay
uh distributions of dark matter is one
electrons are another
and you know by the way for electrons
it's only the simplest ones
that are really spherically symmetric
right the higher level ones the
p d orbitals etc are not spherically
symmetric and look nothing like
dark matter distribution so i would not
read too much into that similarity
charles o'connor says if the fields of
quantum field theory are pervading
space-time in three spatial dimensions
how would you accurately describe the
geometry of waves in those fields
a wave is usually depicted in books as a
two-dimensional sine wave like for
electromagnetism
i've seen them depicted as what i would
call 3d bell curves hiding under a
blanket
i haven't heard an explanation of what
the wave would actually look like as it
moves through its
field so you know
when like for questions like this part
of me just wants to say
you reach a point where you can't
visualize things that's how
science physics works because there's
too many things right
so if space were one-dimensional
then you could easily plot a wave by
sorry we live in three-dimensional space
let me say this exactly right we live in
three-dimensional space macroscopically
if you imagine a hypothetical
one-dimensional world
you can plot a wave in it by plotting
that one dimension but then
also plotting the direction of the field
orthogonal to it that's what you're
ordinarily used to right when you
plot a wave moving in one dimension you
actually draw a two-dimensional plot
the direction in which it's moving and
the value of the field okay
so try thinking about that for a wave in
real three-dimensional space
you would need at least four dimensions
to plot that and you can't visualize
four dimensions very easily
so you just have to trust the math or
use much simpler
examples that's why you see one and
two-dimensional waves
drawn or depicted and not a real
three-dimensional wave you can
do something like it if you really
stretch your mind but then at some point
you're going to have some you know
10-dimensional tensor
defined in three-dimensional space and
you're just not going to be able
to plot that in any interesting way so i
think that the correct answer is
don't try move beyond that think about
in some other way
evan west says can the rent's
contractions occur at the planck length
short answer is yes as far as we know
now we don't know what happens at the
planck length okay
but the planck length is not some
minimum length
that's just not true it again it might
be but we have zero reason to think that
the planck length is some minimum length
it's the length where quantum gravity
becomes important
it's not like some minimal unsqueezable
amount of distance
in physics as we currently understand it
lorenz transformations
contracting the length of things happens
at all length scales
right otherwise you just built a large
thing out of little plonk scale things
and you wouldn't lorenz contract at all
that's not the way it is elias
boyensen boyesen says
what is true about animals that if true
of humans would make it okay to breed
and kill
humans so for example if you would
answer culture would it be okay to kill
humans if that were part of some culture
etc
um so i think that uh what we would need
is to remove
from humans the ability to conceptualize
the future in hypothetical communicable
ways right i've talked about this a
little bit never in great detail
i don't you know i have not really
thought through it uh in all the
philosophical rigor that it would
require
but the idea is that there's something
special about humans that they can
reason about the future and
in that sense understand the prospect of
not being alive
in a way that animals can't you know
animals can be afraid of
being hurt or dying but they can't
really sort of trade off in their minds
in agreement well you know if this
happened then i would cease to exist and
i don't want that to happen
and so thinking about that happening now
makes me sad now even though it hasn't
happened yet
whereas human beings can really do that
very easily so you'd have to remove
from human beings that ability and then
they become like cows or any other
animals
a mandalorian says how does the
heisenberg uncertainty principle apply
to the idea of fixed electron orbitals
if at all
no it applies perfectly well you know
the electron orbital
has a shape in space right the
heisenberg uncertainty principle says
that you cannot have well there's a
minimum combined uncertainty
in position and momentum and the
position of momentum
um has a specific technical meaning
in quantum mechanics and you should
think about the momentum not really as a
velocity
but as a wavelength as a frequency
of variation okay so if a wave is
varying very very rapidly it's high
momentum if it's varying very slowly
it's low momentum
so the heisenberg uncertainty principle
says that when we go to observe
the value of the position or the
momentum of an electron
there's a necessary uncertainty no
matter what the wave function is
and that is absolutely true for fixed
electron orbitals they do not violate
the uncertainty principle in any way
in fact just a little bit more specific
about that um the electron wave orbital
is
kind of spread out in space right it
takes up the space
an angstrom or so that defines the size
of the atom
so delta x is already pretty big the
delta p
doesn't need to be that big to satisfy
the uncertainty principle
brian owenson says do you have a good
explanation why the lagrangian is
kinetic energy minus potential energy
and not something else
leonard suskin says it's kinetic minus
potential because that's what works was
there no better physical sort of
intuitive way to get
to kinetic minus potential um yeah
i don't i mean at the end of the day
lenny is right that is what works and
that's all you ever need okay
um you when you look for these
explanations why
are things one way rather than another
way you got to bottom out somewhere and
you got to say like that's what the laws
of physics are there's no further
explanation behind it
if you want you can sort of think about
what else the lagrangian could be the
lagrangian by the way if any of you
don't know
check out the video i did on force
energy in action
for the biggest ideas in the universe
videos where i explain what lagrangians
are so it's kinetic energy minus
potential energy
well look it certainly can't be kinetic
energy plus potential energy
right or minus kinetic minus potential
because those quantities are constant
they're not doing anything interesting
the total energy is constant
so roughly speaking if you're going to
build something linear
out of the kinetic energy and the
potential energy and you can't add them
together
the next obvious thing to do is to
subtract them and there's no big
difference between kinetic minus
potential
versus potential minus kinetic that
would have been just as good of a choice
in both cases you're looking for
extremal points
of the action and the extremizing either
one of those would give you the same
answer
andrej says you said that the big bang
is similar to a white hole that is a
time reversed version of a black hole
but doesn't such time reversal
require gravity to be repulsive rather
than attractive
so no it doesn't think about throwing a
ball up in the air
right it goes on a paraboloid trajectory
it goes up
and then it comes down and think about
time reversing that right
it's exactly the same thing the time
reverse of that trajectory is it goes up
and then it comes down
so you didn't reverse gravity you didn't
make gravity repulsive you reverse
the initial conditions of the thing of
the ball you were throwing in the air
likewise gravity is absolutely
attractive not repulsive near the big
bang as far as anyone knows
but the stuff the stuff that was banging
was moving apart at a really really
rapid rate
that's the initial conditions that we
have it has nothing to do with gravity
being attractive or impulsive
richard moster says suppose we have
three
ideal clocks the earth clock stays on
earth
my clock goes with me on a spaceship and
a smart clock also goes
with me on the same spaceship but the
point of the smart clock is it is fed
data regarding spaceship acceleration
location etc
whatever it needs to calculate and
display the current time of the earth
clock in the sense that after zipping
around the galaxy
i can return back to earth and the earth
clock and the smart clock will display
the same time
is this possible and if so don't i have
a map at all time between
my clock and the earth smart clocks um
yeah it's perfectly possible and yes
there is such a map uh in fact it's not
a very
uh weird map it's a very well-known map
namely
sitting back here on earth i can create
a coordinate system throughout the
universe based on my time
right in fact that's what that's what we
do in cosmology we slice all of
space-time
and we say here's what time it is now
according to my
everywhere in the universe according to
my clock here on earth
relativity doesn't say you can't do that
relativity just says
you could have done it otherwise right
you could have done many other ways of
slicing the universe into
moments of time equally well so your
smart clock is just keeping time
with respect to this time coordinate
corresponding to
the rest frame of people on earth
there's no problem with that at all
justin walcott says if i understood
correctly you said in the big picture
that free will isn't possible from the
perspective of an omniscient observer
because the current state of the
universe equals the prior state of the
universe plus the laws of physics
what about fictional universes where
magic and deities exist and don't obey
the laws of physics
well it depends on what kind of
fictional universe you're talking about
um the the simple thing is
if there are deterministic laws of
physics
then to laplace's demon omniscient
observer there's no free will because
you know exactly what's going to happen
but something that is equally true
although people seem to have a hard time
grasping it is
there would also be no free will if
there were indeterministic laws of
physics that everything
obeyed if you have for example
quantum mechanics in some truly
stochastic formulation
where wave functions collapse and you
just can't predict what's going to
happen
that doesn't give you any room for free
will because it has nothing to do with
will
has nothing to do with human beings it's
just a random number
thrown there in the laws of physics okay
so what matters for whether physics
will throw their free will for
libertarian free will this sort of
strong version of free will can exist is
are there laws of physics that things
obey
or are things like people or other
conscious creatures
just not subject to the laws of physics
at all
and for people who would wonder whether
or not that's true i always suggest
jumping off of a building and i predict
that the laws of physics
will say what their center of mass
coordinate will do when they jump off
the building and if they think that they
can use their free will
to violate the laws of physics then they
should do that and fly away rather than
hitting the ground
stefan bernicker says how does eric
weinstein's geometric unity attempt to
unify gr with qft
compare to other attempts like string
theory uh i have no idea i'm really
completely
in the dark about what geometric unity
says so i can't really comment on it
simon carter says i recently read lost
in math by sabine haasenfelder
where she argues that modern physicists
obsession with beauty has given us
wonderful math but bad science
stating that there is no law in nature
that says there the universe must comply
with fundamental physicists notion of
mathematical beauty
do you have sympathy for her concerns
well you know
it's certainly technically true that
there is no law in nature that says the
universe must comply with fundamental
physicist notions of mathematical beauty
i think that the implication that
therefore
we should not get too obsessed with
beauty
is wrong i do not follow that logic
because
what we're talking about is
hypothetically
inventing new laws of physics right i
mean there's the kind of physics you do
where you know what the laws are and
you're trying to tease out their
implications right that's most of
physics
and that's perfectly straightforward but
then there is theoretical physics where
you're trying to go
beyond the known laws and figure out
what ones are next
there's literally an infinite number of
laws you could propose that are
compatible with all the data we have
right now
right you need some guidance as to what
possible future laws to take seriously
and which not to take seriously and
personally i think that mathematical
elegance is as good
and as important as any other ones in
part just because it has worked
so far right why would you ignore that
lesson of history
this does not mean that you say well
this is a beautiful
hypothetical law therefore it's true
that's not what science does that's just
not how science works at all
what you say is this is a beautiful
elegant hypothetical law
therefore let's give it a chance let's
take it seriously and try to test it to
try to compare it to the world
i think that's a perfectly legitimate
thing to do
daniele cortese says in your podcast
with david chalmers and philip gough
speaking about philosophical zombies
you claim that since zombies say they
have an experience and are conscious
then none of us know that we're not
zombies because they think they're
conscious like we do
so are you saying that consciousness
could be an illusion or am i
misunderstanding something
so no that i mean from that statement
alone it's compatible with the idea that
consciousness is an illusion but that's
not my perspective my perspective is
there are no such thing as zombies
zombies are not even conceivable
unless you already believe that
consciousness is something that is not
physical right so chalmers and golf
think that consciousness is not physical
that it's something
over and above the physical motions of
matter
and therefore they think we can conceive
of zombies which are
things that physically behave exactly
like we do
but don't have that inner experience of
consciousness since i think that the
inner experience of consciousness
is nothing more than a way of talking
about the physical stuff
going on in our bodies and brains i
don't think that zombies are conceivable
sam says what is one piece of advice you
wish someone had given you before you
entered grad school
um that's always hard because everyone
takes different pieces of advice in
different ways it needs different pieces
of advice
um i would say there's two things
actually even though you just asked for
one you get a bonus
the two things that come to mind are
number one
take initiative you know you're sort of
trained through
years of schooling elementary school
high school
undergraduate school to follow
instructions right
here's the homework do the homework get
the grade take this class
whereas suddenly in grad school you're
supposed to be a working scientist and
working scientists are not supposed to
take instructions they're supposed to
come up with their own ideas
start their own projects read papers
talk to people on their own
and maybe no one tells you that when you
enter grad school but
don't wait for it to come to you go out
and take it is a good piece of advice
the other piece of advice is a little
bit so that's like the first year grad
student advice
then there's the third or fourth grade
your year grad student advice which is
if all goes well in your late undergrad
somewhere between your late undergrad
and early graduate school days
uh you will start writing papers right
you will start
doing science at a professional level
writing papers getting results
submitting the papers getting them
published
and this is an amazingly uh heady
experience like it's
it's thrilling to think that you are
contributing
to the progress of science in some way
and
you probably have spent years looking
forward
to this condition right you've been
waiting for this moment when you can be
a scientist and write papers
and therefore i think it's a little bit
too easy
to say well now i can write papers let's
just write papers let's do research
let's like you know
i'm good at this thing now i can just
keep doing it
rather than being a little bit more
reflective and saying
okay now that i have an existence proof
that i can write a paper
now i should really think carefully
about what papers i want to write right
you know there's a hurdle to overcome
being a published
scientist but then it's a much bigger
hurdle being a public
a published scientist publishing things
that other people care about that
contribute to science that are
interesting okay i think a lot of people
just get
so caught up in the grind of doing what
they're doing
they don't take a step back and say okay
now that i have these powers
how should i put them to best use
chris fautash says you've mentioned many
times about how we see an object falling
into a black hole how it disappears past
the event horizon
but can you describe what would happen
to someone like me once i get past it
well yeah if it's a big black hole
literally nothing at all happens to you
in fact no matter what the size of the
black hole is
there's nothing special about the event
horizon you don't even notice
you could potentially fall into a black
hole and not know it if it was big
enough okay
you might have to be a little bit
clueless about what was going on around
you but you're not
pulled or affected in any way what
eventually affects you is inside the
black hole there are tidal forces
they rip you apart because they pull
very strongly in one direction
compared to the other two directions of
space so this is what is called the
spaghettification
process you are elongated by tidal
forces and eventually ripped apart
but that is not anything localized to
the event horizon at all it gets
stronger and stronger as you pass
through
the event horizon and approach the
singularity
brent meeker says there have been
proposals to use the sun as a lens of a
telescope by the einstein ring
phenomenon
of course the sun is bright and you have
to block out its visible light to make
this work but the sun is transparent to
gravitational waves
and it has varying gravitational
potential higher at the center
so could you use it as a luneborg lens
of a gravity wave telescope
you know yes in principle you could
but in for both visible light and for
gravitational waves the sun is just not
that strong a lens
it's just not that strong a
gravitational field because it's a huge
object
with relatively weak gravitational
fields around it that's why black holes
are good
for these things because they're small
so they take all that mass and they
condense into a small region with a very
strong gravitational field
so the deflection you would get of a
gravitational wave passing through the
sun is
really really tiny and if you've looked
at ligo
and their ability to locate
gravitational wave sources on the sky
localizing gravitational wave sources is
intrinsically incredibly hard
so some tiny deviation of a fraction of
a degree on the sky would be completely
unnoticeable
paul hess says is empty space scale
dependent
would a cubic parsec of emptiness have
34
times more chance of random quantum
stuff happening than a cubic light year
would
well let's unpack the question a little
bit um i'm not quite sure what it means
by
chance of random quantum stuff happening
if you're truly empty
if you're truly in the vacuum there is
zero chance of random quantum stuff
happening you're in a stationary state
uh there's no dynamics there's nothing
changing over time if you're interested
more
about that i wrote a paper with kim body
and jason pollock on why boltzmann
brains do not pop into existence if
you're truly in the vacuum state of
deceiter space and i wrote
blog posts on that too and you can look
that up but otherwise yes
if you're in some non-vacuum state where
there are dynamics and things happening
then the more space
the more things can happen that seems
logical to me
dan o'neil says on new year's eve i
found myself trying to explain
time dilation and special relativity to
my wife and came up with the following
thought experiment
it ignores travel time for light signals
to the observers but is it otherwise
valid and then
i'm editing out but there's a long
description of an of an experiment
so i have to apologize dan this is not
why we're here for the amas
um special i i almost want to sort of
just
ban special relativity questions
entirely because we understand special
relativity there's no mysteries in
special relativity
you can cook up complicated thought
experiments um
but me analyzing these thought
experiments is not
the reason for the ama you can go online
look up the rules of special relativity
and figure them out
sorry to be disappointing i get that it
would be nice if i did this but that is
not
the point of the amas michael buckwitch
says what do you get when you chop an
avocado into 6.022 times 10 to the 23
pieces
i'm sure that what is being looked for
here is some kind of avocados number
joke but i don't quite have it on the
tip of my tongue
brian tidmore says two twins in a
spaceship accelerate at one g
from earth toward alpha centauri one
twin resides in the center hull of the
ship the other twin resides in a chamber
connected to an arm
that rotates around the ship so that she
experiences 1.5 g's
the twins can see each other through the
arm that connects the two locations what
do the twins see as they travel
man i don't know what the hell they see
this sounds like a homework problem if
it's not actually a homework problem
which maybe it is
it certainly seems that way to me uh
maybe you're just trying to tease me
with this kind of question but i think
as i just said before i'm gonna pass on
this kind of question for ama purposes
redbeard says i'm curious to know what
you think about the category of
arguments that includes the simulation
and doomsday arguments
i think they are hard to entertain for
two main reasons the arguments appear to
require
that we place no evidentiary weight on
the input we get from our senses
and i think there is no pathway built
into the arguments that would allow an
observer that is either
not part of the simulation or not an
average observer in the history of our
technological civilization
to determine that he or she is unusual
yeah i don't uh i'm not a fan of the
simulation or doomsday arguments as i've
said
before i think it is just a conceptual
mistake
to start an argument by saying assume
we're typical
in the universe or in some uh category
of people within the universe
we're not typical we are who we are
right we i think that
as good bayesians we should take into
account all the data we already know
i'm a person i'm a physicist i live on
earth
i have a certain age and all those
things that's not typical in the
universe
at all so i do think that there is a
version of these arguments that makes
sense
or let's say not these arguments because
i think that these particular simulation
names the arguments are not right
but there's a version of anthropic
arguments that make sense where you say
i'm comparing two different scenarios
for the universe
and i want to weight them by the
probability that someone
just like me would appear in these
universes
if it's highly likely that a person like
me appears in this universe then that
counts for
that or for that scenario if it's
unlikely a person like me appears and
that counts against it
but that kind of reasoning which i like
has nothing to do with assuming that
you're
average or typical or mediocre in the
universe
pablo's papa giorgio says how does the
gravity of a black hole get out of the
black hole if gravitational waves
normally move at the speed of light well
the gravitational field of a black hole
is not a gravitational wave
you know gravitational wave is a
disturbance that is moving
in the gravitational field it's a ripple
right it's the difference between an
electric field
an electromagnetic wave the
gravitational field of a black hole is
static it's just sitting there
and so the question for a black hole is
what is the solution einstein's equation
for a static spherically symmetric
metric for a distribution of matter or
anything else that's a completely
different question then what is the
dynamical solution to the equations when
you perturb
the gravitational field and let the
perturbations move the answer to that
latter question is
they move at the speed of light but the
gravitational field is not like a
thing that escapes from the black hole
it's just a solution to the equations
including the black hole and the world
around it
will sue says regarding the way people
usually talk about consciousness would
you explain the phrase
what it's like to be something so this
phrase what it's like to be something is
used by people who talk about
consciousness
usually by people who want to emphasize
or lean toward the idea that
consciousness is not purely physical
there what they're trying to do is to
emphasize the first person
aspect of consciousness that whatever
consciousness is they would tell you
it cannot be summed up in objective
third person
outside view statements so this goes
very hand in hand with the
potential interest of the zombie
argument because the point of the zombie
argument is
you can talk to the zombie and from your
outside perspective
they're looking perfectly normal they
look like they act and behave like any
other person
but there's nothing interior that is
experiencing things about the world
so the idea of these people is there is
something that is special
and different from in that first person
perspective of what it is like
to be something so a good example i
heard just the other day is
you can imagine what it is like to be
eight feet tall
okay um you you're not eight feet tall i
presume
but you can imagine what it would be
like you'd have the duck a lot more
airplanes would be a lot less effective
maybe you could get a basketball career
you can imagine what it would be like
there is something called what it would
be like
to be eight feet tall but there's
nothing called
what it would like to be a rock right
because rocks don't experience
the world a rock this rocks don't go oh
yes i have to duck otherwise i will hit
myself and
a chip will fall off or something like
that rocks exist and you can talk about
their external properties
but they don't have internal experiences
william e clark says are you an advocate
of eternalism i.e the block universe
if so how do you reconcile this with our
experience of the flow of time
the money world's interpretation of
quantum mechanics and special relativity
i basically am an eternalist yes
although to be fair
steve savit who is a philosopher at uh
vancouver i think ubc um when he he
watched my biggest ideas video about
time where i talked a little bit about
presentism and eternalism and he pointed
to a paper that he wrote
that says there's really no difference
between being
a so-called presidentist who thinks that
only the present exists
and being eternalist who thinks that all
time
moments exist equally having equal claim
to reality it's just a semantic
distinction it's not really an
ontological distinction i'm a little bit
sympathetic to that
but then i think i told him i bet that
eternalists are sympathetic to this but
presentists are not and he agreed that
presidents don't like his point of view
about that
um so i'm not quite sure what you mean
how do you reconcile this with many
worlds or special relativity
many worlds in special relativity are uh
part of the reason
to be an eternalist they don't treat the
past and present and future any
different
from each other how you reconcile it
with the experience of the flow of time
is a more psychological question
dealing with the fact that there is an
arrow of time that we are dynamical
systems that interact with the universe
we're open systems
and that we're changing over time right
we're experiencing things accumulating
memories
and increasing the entropy of the
universe that's easy to say
actually translating this into a
detailed theory of
the experience of flow of time is harder
i did talk a little bit with jinan
ismail
about this question if you want to go
back to that podcast
miran mizrahi says what is the challenge
of figuring out
ads cft for a universe with positive
cosmological constant
so the adscft correspondence is this
idea that you can take an
anti-dissider space cosmology which is a
solution to einstein's equations with a
negative cosmological constant
and you can imagine certain kinds of
theory of quantum gravity
in that cosmological background that are
actually equivalent
to a field theory without gravity
in one lower dimension so the first
example that juan maldasena who invented
this
thought of was five-dimensional quantum
gravity in anti-decider space and
four-dimensional quantum field theory
and the reason why it works is because
actually from an idea that roger penrose
had
years ago in the 60s where he invented
this idea called conformal
transformations
where basically you can use this to draw
what is called a penrose diagram
which takes an infinitely big space and
squeezes it down to a finite
subset of a piece of paper or whatever
with even the boundary
being squeezed even if the boundary is
infinitely far away so anti-dissider
space
just like flat minkowski space doesn't
literally have a boundary you can go off
in any direction
infinitely far and never hit an edge but
by doing a mathematical transformation
you can bring the whole space
to a finite distance in this
mathematically transformed way
so if that doesn't make sense you have
to take my word for it sorry about that
the point is when you do this for
anti-descender space
the boundary that you bring in from
infinity
has the geometry of a space time of one
lower dimension
so the boundary of five-dimensional
anti-descender space
looks like a four-dimensional flat
space-time
and so it's kind of straightforward to
come up with a potential map
between things going on in ads and
things going on on the boundary
whereas if you don't have that negative
cosmological constant in anti-deceiter
boundary conditions
there's still a boundary that you can
bring in from infinity using penrose's
trick
but it doesn't look like a space time a
space time means you have space
and you have time right and they're
different from each other
so the boundary for d-center space
for the cosmological solution with a
positive cosmological constant
is purely spatial it is not a space-time
it's not
to the left and to the right of you it's
to the future and the past
of you and it's a space-like surface so
there's just no easy way
to map things going on in space in the
future
to things going on into sitter space and
for minkowski space the boundary is
actually
null it is light like if you want
it is a set of it can be constructed
from a set of rays that are all
traveling at the speed of light
so it's also not a space time in any
easy way
so at the very basic level of how the
math could possibly work out
when you're not in anti-sitter space
there's no easy way to make it happen
people have certainly tried to make it
happen in less easy ways but
with let's just say mixed success so far
wes clyburn says what is your favorite
species to have ever existed in the
entire history of the planet
excluding modern human uh i mean i don't
have a favorite species but um
you know i'm a big sucker for the
charismatic megafauna the dinosaurs i
love dinosaurs i
if you dig back into the old days of my
blog you can find reports
of uh going on dinosaur hunting
expeditions
i found uh the fossils of an
edmontosaurus while we were digging up
dinosaurs in wyoming
um and among modern things i like uh
you know cats obviously pictures of cats
but also
falcons and other um predatory birds i
seem to like apex predators
so i'm not sure what that says about my
personality or not
christopher matthews says as an attorney
i can't help but wonder about the
implications the many world's
interpretation could have on our legal
system
well um as i've said before you know i
did write a book about this i know that
there's a lot of
questions we get about many worlds i
wrote a book called something deeply
hidden where i do talk
about this stuff and one of the stuff i
didn't talk about the legal system
specifically but i do talk about
ethical and moral issues which i think
port over fairly naturally into legal
questions
and the answer is there are zero
implications of many worlds for ethical
and moral questions and i think also for
our legal system
um many worlds for all
intents and purposes of people living in
one of the worlds
is exactly like a truly stochastic
copenhagen
type interpretation where something
happens with some probability and you
don't know what it's going to be
but all the evolution of the physical
system up to that point is perfectly
deterministic
many worlds just says that the other
alternatives also come true in other
words but who cares i don't see why that
fact should
in any way change our legal or moral or
ethical implications
yvore trasiev says what is your personal
opinion of girdle escher bach and how it
is aged
science-wise um i love gerda lesterbach
it was one of the
it was it was exactly rightly timed
right to um
fall into my lap when i was in high
school when i was you know
reading all the science books i could
get my hands on that weren't truly
overly technical
and uh it was a little bit technical
right if you read gerda esherbach like
everyone reads the dialogues first and
then goes back and struggles with the
regular chapters but i think it's a
brilliant book i mean
structurally it's amazing uh the fact
that he could do those dialogues and
have all this
intricate typography and everything like
that and still be a bestseller and win
the pulitzer prize
is amazing but also the explanation
of girdle's theorem and all the tying
into girdle's theorem to
recursion and self-awareness and art and
music and so forth i thought was
absolutely lovely and it completely
holds up even today so anyone has not
had a look at girdle usher block by
douglas hofstadter i would absolutely
recommend it hofstadter of course was
the phd thesis advisor of melanie
mitchell who's a previous
mindscape guest tim kennedy says what
are your thoughts on the social contract
as we head into the next 50 years or so
maybe particularly your expectations for
both high and low achievers
so i'm sorry but i have no idea what you
mean by that last clause about high and
low achievers
uh so i can't answer that you know the
social contract i think of as a metaphor
right there's no literal contract
that we write down our names on to sign
but if we live together in a society
that
in which we're in some sense democratic
in
in other words power or authority or
legitimacy
in some sense lies with the people not
with some boss at the top
then some kind of social contract is
implicit that
we do things for the society and society
does things for us and society is just
all the other people
in society different people have been
better or worse at articulating what
this means
but you know one way of putting it is
that almost
no almost nobody in the real world today
is self-sufficient is completely
independent right um
certainly no one who uses electronics
certainly no one who uh
doesn't build their own house with their
own hands and catch their own food and
so forth you can imagine being
self-sufficient
but very few people are we need the rest
of society to live the lives that we do
so some kind of contract is implicit as
long as that ever happens
jim murphy says while reading feynman's
lectures
i found it interesting that he
essentially posits conservation of
energy as an axiom of the universe
after thinking for a while it occurred
to me that the most reasonable
explanation for this fact would be based
on the
uh you say anthropological principle but
i think you mean anthropic
principle universes where energy is not
conserved would not be able to sustain
processes like life in any meaningful
way what are your thoughts on
conservation of energy as evidence
for a cosmological multiverse well
interestingly i just wrote a paper that
you can read
on the archive saying that energy is not
conserved to observers who do quantum
measurements
so clearly i don't think it's necessary
you know
to think that something like
conservation of energy is necessary
i think it depends on how badly it would
be violated right
people tend to think that unless you
have this iron-clad rule
that something is perfectly conserved
then anything goes
and i do think that life would be hard
to sustain in an anything goes universe
but what if energy was just a little bit
not conserved i think that'll be
entirely compatible with life existing
so i don't think there's a good reason
to reach philanthropic explanations in
that particular case
dennis godard says suppose for a moment
we exclude supersymmetry what
alternative mechanisms do you think are
most likely to explain the low observed
value of the cosmological constant
you know we don't even have to exclude
supersymmetry because supersymmetry does
not do the job of explaining the
observed value of the cosmological
constant
um i don't know is the short answer but
i do think you know following tom banks
especially
who's a very well-known physicist who
has pushed the following idea which i do
buy into
that we shouldn't be trying to explain
the lobes or value of the cost module
constant
once you go to quantum gravity
and if you believe in the holographic
principle which i think some version of
is right
then the positive cosmological constant
puts us into sitter space in the far
future an empty space with a positive
cosmological constant
and that means there is a horizon around
us with a finite area and therefore
holography says
a finite number of degrees of freedom
inside that horizon
and there's a relationship between what
the cosmos constant is and how many
degrees of freedom are inside the
horizon so banks says
the thing to be explained is not the low
value of the cosmos constant it's the
high value
of the number of degrees of freedom in
our observable universe i think that is
a
good attitude to take it does not
suggest an answer it does not say okay
therefore
here's the answer but it changes the
question to something i think is going
to be more productive
going forward kirtland edward hobbler
says
what is a good meta-mathematics or
philosophical explanation for why the
complex number system is necessary for
contemporary science
um i have no idea to be honest i mean i
wouldn't
take it too seriously there's a lot of
mathematics that is necessary for
contemporary science why are fourier
transforms
necessary for contemporary science why
are partial differential equations
necessary you know
i don't know why are matrices necessary
i'm not sure that those kinds of
questions ever have simple satisfying
answers
p walder says within the poparian
worldview
when knowledge is created is it being
invented or
discovered i think there's going to be a
later question about this also um
so a number one i have no idea because i
do not hold the popharian worldview uh
so i'm not the expert
uh i've written about falsifiability and
despite my disclaimers people think i'm
writing about popper
my disclaimer is when i write about
falsifiability say
i'm writing about modern contemporary
physicists
cartoon view of pop of falsifiability
not the actual view that karl popper had
i do not pretend to claim to know
what view karl popper actually had um
so i think that knowledge is by
definition
invented uh you don't discover knowledge
you discover facts
and then that gives you knowledge right
i mean for knowledge is a little bit
trickier
the question later on in the ama will be
about theories like theories are clearly
invented
you never walk down the beach and stub
your toe on a theory
right you stub your toe on a rock or a
shell or something like that and then
you invent
a theory to explain it so
knowledge appears right i mean knowledge
is something you learn just by your
senses and then you sort of interpret it
in a theoretical framework
and that theoretical framework has to be
invented so i have no idea what popper
would say about this honestly but that's
my personal
view gregory egan says i can only wrap
my head around the many worlds
interpretation if i concede to infinity
and at least one additional spatial
dimension do you concur
i have no idea about the infinity part
certainly not i do not concur about the
one additional spatial dimension
part there's no need for extra spatial
dimensions in many worlds it works with
whatever number of dimensions you end up
having
dragon tubich says although wheeler
himself denied retrocausality in the
delayed choice quantum eraser experiment
i'm still
unconvinced could you please explain why
the causality is not violated in this
particular experiment
um i can't explain this in real time
people asked this ama question before
i have a blog post exactly on this the
notorious delayed choice quantum eraser
experiment you should go
check that out i explain it in detail
the point is
all of the versions of the delayed
choice experiment that make it seem like
causality is violated
are purposefully confusing they're not
telling you what is really going on so
as to make it seem more mysterious
it all has to do with what you mean by
making a measurement or an observation
so if like me you're an avaredian and
you know what that means
this thing in the delay choice
experiment that is tricky was never
really a measurement at all
if you can undo it it's not a
measurement okay so i explained that in
much more detail in the blog post
i suggest you check it out ken wolfe
says that the expansion of the universe
driven by dark energy continues to
accelerate and we are headed for the big
rip
will there be any way to survive that uh
no
i mean it's literally a singularity in
the future so there's no way to survive
that
i think the big grip is extremely
extremely extremely unlikely
so i wouldn't worry about it suraj rajan
says in the time travel episode
you mentioned that the movie versions of
the watch of a time traveling hero
running fast is
incorrect and that the watch would
actually be showing the passage of time
as personally experienced by the time
traveler
so what would the time traveling twin
appear to have aged less with respect to
does this aging process have something
to do with the entropy of the twins
bodies
so no it has nothing to do with entropy
in the twin paradox there are two twins
both of them have watches right both of
them
have heartbeats and breathing and inner
biological rhythms
that are in synchrony with their watches
and out of synchrony with the watches of
their time-traveling twin
it's there's no unique obvious way to
compare
what those watches say unless the two
twins are at the same point in space
so they start at the same point in space
they can synchronize their watches
they go out and do their things and they
come back to the same point in space and
they can compare
how much time has elapsed for either one
of them but it's
they at no point did either one of them
look down at their own wrists
and see their watch behave weirdly
anonymous says this question is about
general advice for science fiction
writers
consider a setting like the one from
star wars that society has the
technology budget and political will
to build fleets of spaceships and so on
surely the scientists of star wars and
similar settings are building equally
ambitious
even fantastical physics projects for
example using an asteroid belt as
material to construct a massive circular
particle accelerator in space
what kinds of projects would today's
physicists build if a star wars
technology level and budget suddenly
became available
and what are some possible discoveries
that could change society
um it's a very good question actually
it's a tricky one
you know star wars itself and and almost
star trek almost any other
um futuristic tv slash movie space opera
kind of movie
they don't try very hard to invent
realistic things that scientists would
do
in the future right i mean star trek had
recorders
uh or uh um what are the devices you
call when you talk to someone in star
trek i don't know what they are but
basically their iphones right nothing
more tricky than that they were
walkie-talkies highly advanced
walkie-talkies it's not
very very different so they just take
technology we already know
they advance it a little bit so instead
of have guns with bullets you have ray
guns
okay and then you just magically ignore
things like the speed of light so you
say oh i have warp drives so i don't
need to go the speed of light
but there's not any deep thought being
put into
truly society changing
variations like human beings just
mind-melding with computers and
not looking the same anymore that they
that they usually do or human beings
living forever
right there are individual stories
written about these things but
most science fiction stories uh don't
systematically try to take those things
into consideration
i do think that
we are not going to see major changes in
technology
from new fundamental physics i just
wrote a paper saying that that you can
check out
online um but i think that most
technology
technological change will come from the
use of the ingredients we already know
about
in novel creative ways right atoms
molecules
electromagnetic fields etc that kind of
thing
so i don't think you need giant particle
accelerators in space to do that
if you build a giant particle
accelerator in space you can discover
new it'll be great
you can discover new particles right you
could help particle physicists
but almost by construction anything you
discover there
requires a giant particle accelerator in
space to make it
um this is the phase transition that we
went around you know circa 1950
or so before then the things we were
discovering
were already around us we just hadn't
pinpointed them
uh since then the things we're
discovering the top quark the higgs
boson the w boson
there are no ambient higgs bosons lying
around because they decay away
very very rapidly so that's why
fundamental physics doesn't contribute
to technological change
anymore and probably it won't in the
future as far as i can tell
aaron mcbride says how's the quantum
gravity research going
you know it's going fine it's going
slowly everything is slow i'm just slow
because i do lots of different things
at different points in time but you know
we take a step back and rather than
trying to directly
quantize gravity i'm still trying to
work out some fundamental features of
quantum
mechanics you know i wrote a paper with
ash meat singh a couple months ago
trying to see how what are the rules by
which you take an
abstract quantum mechanical theory and
divide it up into subsystems
this seems very down to earth in some
way but it might actually be really
important
for quantum gravity and we're trying to
the next
step on that might be asking why certain
kinds of classical
theories appear as limits of quantum
mechanical theories and other kinds of
classical theories
don't and you can see why these are sort
of good
steps along the way to a full theory of
quantum gravity
the thing i would really like to do and
haven't really made tangible
progress on is take the work that we did
on emergent space time
which we did this is with charles tau
and spiros michalakis
we really only looked at weak field
gravity uh like in the solar system
things like that
when holography kicks in we have a black
hole or cosmology things become very
different
so i want to sort of boot up not boot up
up up level upload no uh i want to
improve our current way of thinking
about it
so that we can take those holographic
non-local effects into account
in the kind of formalism that we built
up deriving space from hilbert space
that's the next obvious step
michael baker says what is the
continuous rotation
why is the continuous rotation of the
galaxies not considered perpetual motion
well you can have perpetual motion
there's no problem with having perpetual
motion there's something called
conservation of angular momentum
right what you can't do is have
perpetual motion
in a world with friction in a world
where there's dissipation of energy
because there is energy conservation to
a good approximation
anyway so galaxies don't have friction
there's nothing stopping them so they're
just going to continue
to rotate alan white says what do you
think of stephen wolfram's physics
project
um i don't know much about it honestly
like they sent me the papers
it's just you know it's not at all
built in a way that would make me get
interested in it because
it just starts from a very very
different starting point and claims
everything
right and it's just not in any way
going to motivate me to read 800 pages
of stuff to get to what i'm interested
in if they really think that for example
they can build quantum mechanics out of
a discrete classical probabilistic
cellular automaton
then write a 10-page paper saying that
and i'd be very interested but i haven't
seen that yet so i haven't been
following
ash wright says is the unlikely state of
entropy at the big bang the only
difference between time and space
dimensions
if one of the space dimensions had a
similarly low entropy would we perceive
time-like effects along that direction
dimension
no it's not the only difference you know
as much as we talk about space time as
being one four dimensional thing
there is a difference between time and
space the simplest
difference is there's only one dimension
of time and there are three dimensions
of space which means in space i can walk
in circles
i can easily leave and come back to
where i left whereas in time i can't do
that there are no
closed time-like curves that would still
be true
even if the big bang did not start with
low entropy
david baldwin says i watched videos by a
gentleman on youtube
named pelosia who addresses ideas like
the kalam
cosmological argument which i know you
know from william lane craig
paul's response is typically that energy
could have always existed
i'd prefer to phrase it that there could
be a first moment in time or that there
could be a larger system involved is
either of us in the ballpark of saying
something
sensible um i think your response is
better but you know they're both kind of
plausible you know the column
cosmological argument for those of you
who don't know
say that says that um
the universe had a beginning everything
that has a beginning has a cause
therefore the universe has a cause
and both those first two premises i
argued in my debate with william led
craig
are not necessarily true they might be
true the universe might have had a
beginning or it might be eternal
we just don't know and the fact that
everything that
that exists or that has a beginning has
a cause is just an outdated
philosophical way of thinking about what
you mean by
cause the correct question to ask is not
what is the cause of this
but is this happening compatible with
the laws of physics and again
we don't know whether a universe with a
beginning is compatible with the laws of
physics or not
we have no reason to think it's not we
just don't know what those laws physics
are so we can't say so
quite yet ashley hyatt says
how do cosmologists estimate the amount
of matter and energy in the universe
well there's different ways to do it i
mean you can't even try
or you could try you can't successfully
measure the amount of estimate of matter
and energy
in the whole universe you can do it for
the observable universe right but
outside the observable universe we
can't really say anything with any
confidence we can just guess which is
fine but it's not really
very reliable inside we use gravity
right gravity is the one thing that
always couples to matter and energy
so you can have matter energy that are
invisible to photons or to neutrinos or
to whatever
but everything both causes and is
influenced by
gravity so you can use that gravity in
different ways you can use it locally
like in a galaxy or clusters just
see how fast things are moving and
therefore estimate the gravitational
fields and therefore the amount of stuff
or you can look at the expansion and
dynamics of the universe as a whole
that's the that's the most reliable
thing to do because then you count
everything and that is what
modern cosmologists do to get the
answers that they get
kc says please speculate on whether the
everett branching creates a new universe
quantum field
or is there only one i don't know what
that means a universe quantum field
quantum fields exist within universes
okay so within every universe
there are a bunch of quantum fields and
so every time you branch
you have a new space time new quantum
fields the whole bit
linear miziarra says in frank wilcheck's
wonderful book fundamentals he says that
the cosmic horizon is expanding
how is this possible if the expansion of
the universe is accelerating
well the cosmic horizon is roughly well
sorry it's exactly
exactly given if you assume there was a
big bang okay that's that's where the
roughly comes in assume there is a big
bang
14 billion years ago which is a boundary
past which we can't see
the cosmic horizon is what you get if
you take our current position in space
and trace the
light cone backwards until you hit the
big bang
so the light cone going into the past is
a big spherical thing
expanding and expanding until it hits
the big bang
so the cosmic horizon is getting bigger
just because we're getting older just
because we're aging more
and therefore the past light cone is
enclosing more and more stuff
that's going to be true whether or not
the universe is accelerating
enrique arreola says if black holes are
formed in part by the presence of mass
and most of the mass is a product of the
strong force holding quarks together
what happens to the strong force once
the black hole is formed
so it's what you say is almost true but
i wouldn't say
most of the mass is a product of the
strong force holding quarks together you
know there's
the mass or the energy equivalently in
some object
is inherent in whatever the fields in
that object are doing
if you have a thing with made of protons
and neutrons
then the energy comes from or is
described by a configuration of
those quarks and and um quarks coupling
to the gluons namely the strong force
now that can convert into other forms of
energy the energy can be conserved even
if the
strong force uh fields convert into
other kinds of fields
like the neutral pion okay a pion
neutral particle one quark one antiquark
it can decay into two photons
keeping the total energy the same so you
start with
two quarks or a quark and an antiquark
bound together by gluons
they convert into two photons so there
was strong force there
there no longer is but the total energy
is conserved so when you make a black
hole out of things that have the strong
force in them there's nothing
to prevent that particular strong force
field configuration from turning into
something very different
mike briggs says i've heard you say that
you believe in many worlds wouldn't it
be better to say
convinced by uh no i have no problem
using the word believe to represent my
beliefs
i think a lot of people confuse the word
belief
uh to mean belief without evidence or
you know belief against evidence or you
know belief based on faith or something
like that
you can have belief based on evidence
that's what i have and so that's why i'm
happy to use the word
jason says to what extent is the spin of
a particle such as an electron
analogous to the spin of a macroscopic
object such as a basketball
it's it's largely analogous i mean the
real difference is
that when you measure the spin you get
these quantized answers
um also there is there's a lot of
confusion in books
in textbooks written about this if you
were to
think of electrons as little literally
point particles
or even as little spheres
of constant density and everyone knows
they're not spheres of constant density
but imagine that they weren't okay
neither in the point particle idea nor
the sphere idea could you literally have
an electron
spinning at the radius the electron is
supposed to have
at a velocity less than the speed of
light to account for its spin and
therefore people have said
the spin of an electron is not really
spin it's not really angular momentum
but we know that what electrons really
are are not
point particles or little spheres
they're
field configurations so my caltech
friend
uh chip sabins who i wrote the paper
with on the probability rule in many
worlds quantum mechanics
he's been working on trying to
understand things like energy and spin
in a real quantum field theory context
and what he says is the spin is just the
angular momentum of the field
that's all it is it's just angular
momentum just like you always thought it
was
i'm not a super expert on that but his
argument seemed convincing to me
keith says in everwriting quantum
mechanics can split wave function
branches evolve to an almost identical
or identical state
essentially giving that state multiple
possible histories within the universal
wave function
at least on very small time scales um
i'm not exactly sure what is going on in
this question sorry about that
i mean split wave functions can evolve
to an almost identical or identical
state you know imagine um
well it's always hard because we always
have assumptions in the back of our mind
so we don't always explicitly lay out
what i was going to say
is imagine measuring two spins okay
and you get one spin up and one spin
down if you get
spin up and then spin down you end up
in the same position as if you got spin
down and then spin down right if you did
the same spin i should say the same spin
you just measure it twice
um but of course if you recorded
the answer then somewhere in your brain
you know what happened in the past so
it's not really the same kind of thing
um if what you mean is i mean two
what i'm trying to say is two branch the
wave function can look very very very
similar
essentially as similar as you want them
to look
but then you say giving that state
multiple possible histories within the
universal wave function
i'm not sure what what exactly that
means i mean of course
a state can have multiple possible
histories because the it can branch
so i think that you're assuming
something that is not quite clear to me
sorry about that
jim cecilian says have you considered
inviting colin woodard author of
american nations as a guest
i have not but i always like to get
suggestions
duncan palmer says do you believe it is
possible or even inevitable that
computational algorithms will develop
some of the next important breakthroughs
in theoretical physics
and if so does it matter if the human
mind understands how the algorithm
connects input data to observed output
or simply the algorithms work in fitting
the data i can certainly imagine
that algorithms will develop some of the
next breakthroughs in theoretical
physics you know i don't think we should
be too
um parochial about our own human
abilities why shouldn't computers be
able to do it uh
whether or not we can understand what
they've been done you know i think it's
it's useful either way it's more useful
if you can
understand it right so if a computer
comes up with a theory
of theoretical physics but the computer
tells us you know
the theory is just too complicated
you'll never understand it but if you
ask me a question i can give you the
answer
that's useful in certain obvious ways
but it's not
nearly as useful as being told the
theory in a way you can understand it
okay
so either one is is interesting but
there's definitely one better than the
other
elias concoula says if you could
experience a historical event in person
what would it be
um yeah i don't know i mean i thought
about this uh
i don't know i i presumably were talking
about past historical events right
um i'm not a big fan of the idea of
going to the past you know the past was
a terrible place they didn't have good
uh sewage they didn't have good hygiene
or they didn't have
uh good safety in all sorts of different
ways the it was a hard life
in many kinds of ways and you know i
think i would rather
just be now and still age into the
future and read about the past in
history books so sorry
i'm not giving your answer a good your
question a good answer but this is
i'm more of a future-oriented person
than a past oriented person
alan gebhardt says this relates to the
hard question of consciousness as
presented by david chalmers
assuming that sensory input increases
with the complexity of organisms
and that a self-reflective consciousness
provides significant survival advantages
how is it a problem to posit that such a
deliberative executive functionality
is a natural development of darwinian
adaptations across species
so it's not and david chalmers be the
first to agree that it's not a problem
at all but that's what he calls the easy
problem that's not the hard problem
the hard problem of consciousness is not
deliberative executive functionality
it's explicitly not that's the easy
problem the hard problem is
the inner first person subjective
experience
what it is like to be eight feet tall as
we were saying before
that's the thing that chalmers says it's
hard to explain harder than the
simple darwinian explanation of
functionality in any sense
jorge says watching the biggest ideas i
understood that at least in the context
of effective field theory
the constants like the fine structure
constant alpha are not constant but
functions of the cutoff energy
in that case when you say that for
example alpha is one over 137
which cutoff energy is being considered
and why
so yeah that's a very good question and
the answer is zero energy
so in other words we measure alpha the
fine structure constant by scattering
particles off of each other
with some mutual energy between them and
we take the limit as that energy goes to
zero
and that is what we quote as the value
of alpha being one over 137 at higher
energies
alpha is a slightly bigger number
if i'm getting the sign right i think
that's right for the strong interactions
for example
you can't do that the the zero energy
limit blows up it's infinite the
coupling constant so
for the strong interactions you have to
define the strong coupling constant at
some other energy other than zero
usually defined to be the qcd scale
around 300 million electron volts or
something like that
christian dobo says it seems to me
governments and organizations sometimes
choose to distort or simplify facts for
the public's own good
when there are not enough ppes they
might say it's not effective anyway
when arguing with anti-vaxxers they say
no vaccine ever causes serious side
effects etc
nothing is ever black or white but what
do you think in general of society's
right and capacity to know and handle
the truth
where would you draw the line i think
you know the society has uh the right
and capacity to know and handle the
truth i think you should tell the truth
and i think that
it doesn't do much it's not very
conceptually useful
to blame quote unquote governments and
organizations
right there are people who make up these
governments and organizations and these
people make these choices and different
people might make different
choices so i think that you should be
honest with the public
for various reasons there are exceptions
to that you know there are
sort of self-interest uh danger
situations where
you don't want to give away your battle
plans in public if you're in the middle
of a war or something like that but
when it comes to the safety and and
things that the public themselves should
be doing
just tell them the truth tom says what
do you think of the name the second law
of thermodynamics
i studied physics and philosophy at
university and we did a short curse on
course on entropy
and i never understood it because they
kept calling it a law and it seemed
obvious that it wasn't a law it was just
a likelihood
how can you get anything profound out of
a likelihood
well if something is if something has a
likelihood that is 99.99999
you can get some very useful things out
of that right if someone's willing to
bet you even money
on coin flip and you know the coin is
not fair
and it's a 60 chance of being heads you
can make a lot of money out of that
there's all sorts of likelihoods that
are very very profound so i think that's
my answer
gary miller says in your mindscape
episode with max tegmark you mentioned
that the high resolution of our universe
may signal that we are in
the real thing however could there be a
selection
pressure for high quality simulations
like the creator of the simulation
prefers high quality simulations
well two answers to that one is sure i
mean there could be who knows that's why
you see very quickly how this kind of
speculation becomes ungrounded from
things we can actually
check against any experiment right but
the other thing is my argument was not
just
it could be lower resolution it's that
we will make simulations ourselves right
our civilization will simulate others if
you believe this kind of reasoning
and ours will necessarily be lower
resolution than
the simulation that we are supportedly
supposedly in
and therefore it's just inevitable that
most simulations are the low resolution
ones regardless of selection pressure
again i don't think that the original
argument for the simulation
hypothesis really works but i think
that's a one of the possible
objections to it anonymous says there
are about as many human thought moments
0.1 seconds in a human lifespan as there
are human lifespans in the age of the
universe
is that some sort of anthropic maximum
likelihood thing
as far as i know no i think that you
know it's numerology
as far as i can tell maybe if you come
up with some explanation i'd be willing
to think about it but
as far as i know no christopher
gustafson says
is there a globally agreed upon map
structure for all the known stars
planets galaxies among people working
with astronomy
well there are two things you when you
talk about something in the sky
whether it's galaxies or stars or
whatever you talk about
its position on the sky you know the
far away stars are almost stationary
over human lifetime they don't move very
much
there is a reference frame with respect
to which you can locate things on the
sky
there's a universal map structure for
that called right ascension and
declination
and the third dimension is just the
distance to the thing and the problem
with the distance is we usually don't
know it
right there's it's very very hard to
measure distances
of things in astronomy as we found out
talking to uh
lena nasib and also adam reese on the
podcast in 2020.
so that's often not listed when you talk
about positions of things on the sky
it's just
much harder to map distances than
angular positions on the sky
lng says it seems logical that if there
is any place in the universe
where information is not preserved it is
inside a singularity
why not accept this and face the
consequences accordingly
so i presume you're talking about the
black hole information loss puzzle
and the point is the black hole
evaporates away
so it the point is you go from a
situation where there is no black hole
and then you evolve through a situation
where there's a black hole but then
in the future again you have no black
hole
so there are laws of physics quantum
mechanical laws of physics
that evolve you from no black hole to
black hole and quantum mechanics
preserves information so the options are
either
that there is something that is that
that picture is just entirely wrong
right that you don't have an evaporating
black hole in some sense or another
or that quantum mechanics is wrong in
some way
or that information somehow gets out and
of those three options the information
somehow getting out
seems to be the mildest okay i mean sure
maybe
uh information could not be uh preserved
in black hole evaporation
but that leads to all sorts of other bad
things like you can have virtual black
holes enfinement diagrams
all the time so you would have
information being lost
all the time and in ways that we don't
seem to actually observe it
so none of these are airtight arguments
but that's why people have the opinions
that they do
samuel val says based on your experience
as a student and professor of physics
are there any issues or changes you
would make to this post-graduate process
of a phd in physics
um i guess there's one change that i
would
take very seriously which is i don't
know whether current postdoctoral
fellows would would like this change but
i think we should have fewer postdocs so
right now
in physics you get a phd it takes five
six years or whatever
then you get a postdoc and so that lasts
for three years
and you just do research and you build
up your cv your experience
and many people do two or sometimes
three or more
post docs then eventually you either get
a faculty job or you get some other job
you leave the field or you go into
industry
or whatever and the number of
faculty jobs everyone who goes into the
phd program
not everyone but the vast majority of
people would like to get a faculty job
doing physics but the number of faculty
jobs is much smaller than the number of
graduate students
so there is a bottleneck and you have to
choose where to put the bottleneck you
can't get rid of the bottleneck
except by just dissuading people from
wanting to be physicists which i don't
think is the right strategy
so right now there's a huge bottleneck
in going from post doc
to faculty member most postdocs do not
become faculty members
and i think that's too late in life you
know i mean you get your phd
you're 26 27 28 years old and then you
get another
six eight years of postdocking you're in
your mid-30s
before suddenly you have to change your
career and that's hard to do at that
point in life
i think that getting a phd in
theoretical physics
probably also in experimental physics
although i'm just admitting that my
experience there is not as
as big is intrinsically valuable no
matter what you go on
to do it's good training whereas being a
postdoc in physics
is just more of the same it's you know
better training but it's in the same
kind of vein as your graduate student
training so i think where the bottleneck
should be is closer to after being a
graduate student than after being a
postdoc so i think there should be fewer
postdocs to be honest
eric chen says what's the argument for
why humans should try to reason
like bayesians even if we accept
something like
solomonov induction as the correct
account of ideal reasoning what's the
further justification that boundedly
rational agents like us should try to
approximate this ideal when reasoning in
practice
well you know i think the phrase
basinging bayesian reasoning is a little
bit
vague it's a little bit of a catch-all
there's different aspects of the story
that go into what we call
bayesian reasoning and so you could
question um
different ones of them so one aspect is
just accepting baze's rule
right accepting that if you have some
priors on different propositions and you
get
new data you can update those credences
that you have in those
uh propositions by baze's rule i mean
invasive rule is just true you have
don't have a
choice it's a theorem you can derive it
it's it's inherent in the meaning of
what you mean
by conditional probabilities there's
really no option there
there is a question of practice like
when you
actually update your uh credences and
different beliefs
very few people in the everyday world
literally write down their priors and
then calculate likelihood functions and
multiply them and all that stuff
so maybe that's where the bounded
rationality comes in you want to
approximate
that procedure by a way that is easier
than actually plugging in
faces rule that's fine but you want to
approximate it as well as you can so i
would still say that you are
trying your best to be bayesian but then
there are other aspects
one aspect is the very idea that
probability should be subjective
right i mean there are people who just
reject the bayesian
philosophy that the way to think about
probability is
a set of credences which you then update
when new information comes in
um i just think those people are wrong
i'm in favor of the subjective view of
probability so i think that's a sensible
way to treat
credences and how to manipulate them
peter bamber says is a wormhole linking
space inside the event horizon of a
black hole
to space outside the event horizon a
valid solution to the equations of
general relativity
uh no it's not at least you can always
start with a wormhole linking them but
like i said earlier in the ama
the wormhole just collapses a
traversable wormhole
with positive energy sources is not a
good solution to general relativity
sorry
chris vigorito says how would you
describe the difference between an ether
and a quantum field on a superficial
level they seem to be similar in concept
well the big difference is the entire
point of the ether was
supposed to define a rest frame for the
universe right you could measure your
speed with respect to it
and quantum fields don't do that quantum
fields exist in space time but they look
the same to all observers no matter how
they're moving therefore it's quite
different from the ether
yahel guberman says regarding life
outside earth you say that we have a
sample size of one so life could be
ubiquitous or rare
life appeared on earth fairly early on
and we have no evidence that life
evolved independently more than once on
earth doesn't that count as evidence
against ubiquity
well the fact that life appeared on
earth fairly early on might count as
evidence for
ubiquity but i think that either
evidence is very very
weak you know maybe life would have
evolved on earth many times but the life
that already existed
sort of ate it up right destroyed the
competitor life
uh we just don't know any of these
things so i think that still we should
just be open-minded about this
damien alexiev says what are your
thoughts on herman minkowski's statement
that space by itself and time by itself
are doomed to fade away into mere
shadows
and only kind of union of the two will
preserve an independent reality
i think that statement is very very
accurate as far as the philosophy of
relativity is concerned either special
relativity or
general relativity since we don't yet
have a good quantum theory of gravity
we can't be sure that that philosophy
will continue to be true
but it's certainly been very successful
over the past hundred years
david grimes says it was recently
proposed that black holes could have
formed orders of magnitude larger than
supermassive black holes
there could be stupendously large black
holes there rise to mass 100 billion
solar masses however reports also state
that assaulted black holes could not
grow larger than 50 billion solar masses
due to the way accretion works
what is it about the supermassive black
hole accretion process and the special
areas of space-time surrounding such
monsters
that keep them from growing further so
i'm not a super expert on this but my
superficial understanding is
it's not anything specific with black
holes or
you know weird general relativity
effects it's the accretion process
if you have a very big black hole
anything can fall into it and you know
part
one particle at a time you can
absolutely pour more mass onto it
but the point is that if you try to
accumulate a lot of matter in a giant
accretion disk
it heats up and then pushes the rest of
the matter away
it becomes harder and harder to sustain
a sort of quasi-equilibrium
configuration where matter is constantly
accreting onto the black hole
i really don't know anything about these
stupendously large black holes but that
is the
little bit of knowledge that i have alan
rasmussen says
do you see the number of spatial
dimensions experienced by humans and use
the newtonian and quantum mechanics as
three
as an emergent or fundamental property
my guess is that it's an emergent
property i think that all space time is
probably emergent and that includes the
dimensionality
but again we don't know for sure anton
hawthorne says i've heard talk about a
multiverse in the sense of inflation
causing the separation of bubble
universes
where physical constants can vary
between them my question is
what theory predicts these constants to
not be constant why would we expect them
to vary over cosmic distances
so there's a few different theories that
predict that by the way they're not
necessarily true
these theories so it's absolutely
possible
to imagine a multiverse in the sense of
eternal inflation with bubble universes
where all the constants are the same
it's somehow more fun to imagine than
being different so that's often what
people do and the anthropic principle
doesn't work unless they're different so
that's another motivation
so the simplest motivation is actually
extra dimensions
of space which is predicted by string
theory and might even be true of string
theory is false
once you have extra dimensions of space
you need to hide them somehow
generally the simplest way to do that is
to curl them up into some small
topological geometric manifold and there
are many many ways to curl up the extra
dimensions
and it turns out that once those extra
dimensions are curled up you can't see
them anymore macroscopically from the
big three dimensions
but they sit there setting the
background values of various constants
in your low energy effective theory
including the fine structure constant
the masses of particles the higgs boson
expectation value all these different
things that go into particle physics as
we know them
could be different depending on the
topology and the geometry of the extra
dimensions
so it's very possible that in the
inflationary multiverse that is actually
what happens
again we don't know for sure ellen
maroczyk says
do you think there is something that we
can think of as a cognitive wall
by cognitive wall i mean a limit to what
can be learned processed and understood
within one human lifespan or that helps
certain topics
that certain topics have too many
variables to consider
uh you know sure i think there's
absolutely a finite calculational
capacity of the human mind and the
effective capacity is probably much less
than the
in principle capacity if we treated
every neuron as a perfect computer
so you know if you take two numbers both
of which have 10 to the 100 digits
and asked me to multiply them in my head
i'm not going to be able to do it
but i have no idea what that cognitive
wall is in practice and i
am suspicious of any idea that you know
we're close to it now in terms of
developing new theories of physics or
anything like that
i think it's a long way to go before we
reach the levels of our understanding in
those regimes
alexander cordova says how is it that
some dimensions are smaller than other
dimensions in the context of possible
extra dimensions existing
well as i just said you could imagine
curling them up so
the usual metaphor which i can't do any
better than is to imagine a straw
like a sipping straw or a rubber hose or
something like that where one dimension
is very very long
the length of the straw and the other is
curled up into a little circle
okay so this is topologically
a line if you imagine an infinitely long
straw that's a line in long direction
and a circle in the short direction
and as you sort of move further and
further away from the straw that extra
curled up dimension looks smaller and
smaller and the straw looks more and
more
like a literal one-dimensional line so
in particular in our universe where you
have quantum mechanics and particles and
fields have wavelengths
if the wavelengths of the particles and
fields that we know about are all
much larger than the sizes of the extra
dimensions
then those extra dimensions would be
invisible to us
craig gordon says are all the force
carrier particles
virtual if not what is the difference
between a real photon gluon w and z
boson compared to a virtual one
so no they're certainly not all virtual
i mean the photons that are hitting your
eyeballs right now are not virtual
photons they're real photons
the word virtual in this sense only
and explicitly means particles that are
in the interior of feynman diagrams
so we use feynman diagrams to think
about scattering processes
two electrons scatter off of each other
by exchanging a virtual
photon but if any particle is at the
edges of the finemen diagram not on the
interior one that either comes in from
the outside or goes
out at the end of it in going or
outgoing particles
those are all real so photons gluons wz
bosons can all be real
john eastman says have you seen the
netflix series surviving death
episode 6 featuring jim tucker's
fascinating research on children with
memories of past lives uh nope
i have not seen that marco fayela says
regardless of current technological
limitations or from the point of view of
an extremely advanced civilization
what would be the pros and cons of
communicating via gravitational waves
well they would almost all be cons
because gravity is really really weak
which means it's incredibly hard to both
create a gravitational wave and to
detect it
it's much much easier to create or
detect photons or even neutrinos
compared to gravitational waves so
unless you were really like locked in
some completely opaque region of space
and wanted to get signals out there's
almost no circumstances under which i
could imagine gravity waves
being the way to go john smith says
assuming the many world's interpretation
is a correct interpretation of quantum
mechanics here's my question
uvif fragrance it's a sort of
nonsensical phrase
i assume in one of these many worlds
you'll be able to understand this
gibberish and answer my question let's
hope it is in this world
uh i don't want to waste your time so
nope it's not this world it's just
gibberish sorry about that
anon says why do you assume that the
entire opposition to democrats is
anti-democratic
uh i don't not at all not any possible
sense
andrei dinu says would you agree to the
following description of reality
ignoring complications related to
particle spin a system of n
particles is defined by a complex valued
wave function of three
times n variables if the wave function
is real then the three n dimensional
space is real too
and this means the answer to the
question about where everett's world
actually
exists is simple they are nothing but
peaks of a wave function in the 3n
dimensional configuration space
well i edited that down so i hope i get
the essence of the question there
the point is that the world is not a
system of n particles as far as we know
our best models of the world are as
quantum fields which have a continuum of
possible values
it might be in fact i think it probably
is the quantum field theory is just an
approximation
and there's some underlying finite
dimensional structure
but it's not a set of n particles right
so
i think that the thing that exists is
hilbert space right the or the wave
function as an element of hilbert's
space
evolving through hilbert space that
seems to me to be the right way to think
about reality
avi chain says i'm an undergrad physics
major
last semester i took quantum mechanics
i'm trying to understand spin
of elementary particles how should i
imagine it is it similar to a
classically spinning object
so yes as i said earlier once you go to
quantum field theory it becomes easier
to see
how to think of of elementary particles
with spin
as classically spinning objects as
objects with angular momentum
even at the level of just point particle
quantum mechanics where that work
doesn't work
you have to just attribute some quantity
called spin to this point particle
called the electron
geode it's a kind of angular momentum
it's an intrinsic angular momentum it
can't change
the electron always has spin a half
there are no electrons would spin three
halves
it can't rotate faster but it's an
intrinsic amount of angular momentum
that's what it is
i i don't i don't see why that's hard to
think about i never really struggled
with that one
alexei zablotsky says i've
watched max tag mark's mathematical
universe thing and quickly became
convinced but there's a problem
there are more complex mathematical
structures than simple ones and our
actual law of physics
seems simple so imagine a sequence of
random bits with length
l and some subsequence around it and
then interpret it in some simple formal
language
breathing fire into the equations and
then it goes on longer than that
uh so there's two things to say about
the scenario that you're sketching out
one is i'm really not sure what to make
of the idea of
being interpreted in some simple formal
language therefore breathe breathing
fire into the equations
i think the metaphor of breathing fire
into the equations uh is a vivid one
but i have no idea what it means i have
no idea to operationalize that
or understand what it means i understand
the universe as stuff
evolving according to patterns so when
you say the mathematical universe
i interpret it as there's some stuff and
there's some patterns that's what you
give me
i agree with you that in the world of
all
complex mathematical structures way more
of them
are complicated and messy than simple so
unless
there is some principled reason to pick
out the simple ones that's why i don't
think
that tegmark's mathematical universe is
very convincing i would expect i would
make a prediction
on the basis of that model that our
universe looks very very different than
it does
we don't understand enough about the
space of all mathematical structures to
say that definitively
but that's why i don't think it's uh
it's promising as of our current level
of understanding
jonathan gordon says could you do an
interview with judea pearl on his book
about the science of cause and effect
called the book of why
always happy to get suggestions as i
always like to say
tim allman says one of the first things
we all learned about quantum mechanics
is that matter and anti-matter will
annihilate each other
in a flash of gamma rays should they can
contact each other
however mesons which consist of a quark
and an antiquark exist
even if only for a short time and when
they decay they produce particles such
as electrons rather than photons that
one might expect
why is that so number one mesons can
decay into photons as i already said
that's what neutral pions for example do
they decay into pions
but it never was true that quantum
mechanics taught that matter and matter
annihilate into photons as some
exclusive thing
particles and antiparticles annihilate
into other particles
it could be all sorts of other particles
as long as the particles they annihilate
into
are not heavier than the total energy of
the system that did the annihilating
in the first place so that's why when
you collide an electron and a positron
they're roughly speaking aren't any
particles lighter than them to
annihilate into other than photons
there are exceptions there could be
gravitons or neutrinos right
but both gravitons neutrinos interact
really really really weakly
so you will make them sometimes when
electrons annihilate it's just really
really unlikely
but if other particles annihilate like
if you have a uh w boson and an anti-w
boson they can annihilate all sorts of
things not just photons
jason levy says we assume that our
senses and our level of intelligence are
enough to comprehend any truth about the
nature of nature given time in the
proper thinking
is it possible that that is a
misperception do you think it's possible
the most fundamental questions of
physics are beyond the reach of human
understanding
well you know it's related to the
question i just talked about
in some sense in some strict sense sure
it's absolutely possible that there are
questions that are beyond the reach of
human understanding it would be foolish
to assume otherwise
on the other hand don't leap from there
to therefore i suspect it's true that
there are questions beyond the reach of
human understanding it's possible
that doesn't mean it's likely my
personal view is that
human understanding human ability to uh
think about the word cog uh about the
world
cognitively rationally and abstractly
has undergone some kind of phase
transition right we can model formal
systems in our minds in ways that other
animals cannot
and that gives us a certain ability
which might be all you need
to answer the fundamental questions of
physics we're basically touring machines
right
you might not need more ability than
that so
it's up in the air but i would be
skeptical of worries
that there are fundamental questions we
can't understand
anders says if a mouse made it into your
house who would catch it first
ariel caliban you or your wife well it
would not be me or jennifer
it would be between ariel and caliban
ariel is much faster and more energetic
so she if she moves quickly enough she
has a chance but caliban is
is stronger he's a big 15 pound cat and
he's all muscle
uh he's also very very patient so if the
mouse like hid
in some nook or cranny caliban would
wait for it to come out so he'd probably
be the most likely
mark eimel says in your recent podcast
with avi loeb he mentioned that amumua
is more or less at rest in the local
galactic frame are there cosmological
models that would predict
rocks being at rest to local galactic
rest frame
um sure every cosmological model i mean
the point is just that the galaxy
is full of stuff right full of stars
full of
rogue planets and comets and and pieces
of riff raff and whatever
with various velocities so some of them
are going to be at rest in the galactic
rest frame just by chance
um avi is trying to make a point that
it's weird that most things are not at
rest
or close to it but some things are going
to be that's not so surprising all by
itself
eric coker says what inspired the term
mindscape for your podcast i asked
because i just picked up rudy rucker's
infinity in the mind
and the term figures predominantly in
the first chapter is there any
relationship
so there's no relationship between rudy
rucker's book sorry i didn't know about
that
um it was just a word we came up with
you know bouncing ideas around i had
lots of ideas early on most of them were
pretty bad
and you know i googled it and the word
mindscape certainly exists
out there in the world but there was no
like really famous book
or other podcast called that so we went
with it
beth mowry says read the
idea of alternate versions of ourselves
existing in parallel universes
do these versions split off every time a
choice is made
so no choices have nothing to do with it
this is again something i discuss in
detail
in something deeply hidden versions
split off when the universe branches
and the universe branches when a quantum
mechanical system becomes entangled with
a wider macroscopic world in particular
with its environment one way or the
other
those words have nothing to do with
human beings making choices
now it can happen the other way around
it can happen that a quantum event
can affect a choice you make and
therefore a single quantum splitting can
have a effect so that in one universe
you make one choice in another universe
you make another one
but it's the event that causes the
difference in your choice making
not the other way around jack lyle says
why is the charge on electron exactly
equal to minus the charge on a proton
in 1911 this was a just so story but is
is it still one today
well as far as we know
uh yes it is it is just a just so story
it just
that just happens to be the truth but we
have ideas
as to why it might be true the most the
simplest most compelling one
is um grand unification so we
have these forces of nature the strong
the weak and the electromagnetic
uh su-3 cross su-2 across u1 and since
the 70s people have tried to unify these
three forces into a single
simple gauge group like su-5 or
something like that
and it turns out that if you do that
then you predict
quantization of the different charges
and part of that is that uh all
electrons have the same charge
and it is minus the charge of a proton
that that is a prediction of grand
unification
but we don't know if grand unification
is true so we have to be a little bit
open-minded about that
david whitmarsh says how might one
someone experimentally test whether the
everett interpretation of quantum
mechanics is correct
well you can do any experiment at all in
quantum mechanics and
ever will make a prediction and you can
see whether that prediction is right
probably what you're asking is how can
you experimentally test whether it's
incorrect could you falsify it somehow
and there yes
just see an isolated quantum system
violate the schrodinger equation that's
all you need
and indeed experiments are ongoing to
test exactly that but so far
they haven't seen any violations
probably because everett is correct
richard taylor says imagine that as an
undergraduate you were abruptly
transported to the year 2021
what would impress you the most about
this world of the future and what would
be your greater
greatest disappointment um so here again
i think that all of my answers are
extremely conventional i don't have
anything clever to say to this question
uh you know the most impressive thing is
in various versions
the internet and electronic connections
that we have between us right
um you know for my undergraduate days
we were regularly flying the space
shuttle in the concord so
there's no rule that says that
technology has to advance
you know we can have technologies and
regular use that we lose
use of but obviously the ability to
do podcasts on the internet read them on
my
computer or listen to them on my cell
phone these are none of those words
would have made any sense when i was an
undergraduate
so that's impressive not again not very
surprising that that's the answer but
it's an impressive one
um and the disappointing things are
things like climate change which we
already knew about in the 80s but
was you know something that seemed a
little bit less um
obviously disastrous than it does now
and the threats to democracy which you
know are always there in the background
but they were way in the background
in the 1980s you know we saw the cold
war going on when i was an undergraduate
but
it was kind of becoming clear that the
soviet union
was not robust you know i think that
people will
tell themselves they saw the collapse of
the soviet union coming even though
maybe they didn't i certainly didn't
predict it was going to happen
nearly as quickly and dramatically as it
did
so that was at the time you know the
threat of nuclear war
was very real when i was an
undergraduate and it's not now i mean
the threat of a rogue nuclear explosion
is bigger now
than it was then but a full-scale
nuclear war seems less likely
but we have things like um rising
authoritarianism and climate change that
i'm very worried about those are my
greatest disappointments
josh says in something deeply hidden you
mentioned that the many worlds
don't really exist and are instead just
a useful tool for human thought can you
elaborate on this point um
you're gonna have to bring up a quote on
that because i never remember saying
that i usually say exactly the opposite
i think the other worlds do
really exist that is my view siddhartha
says
even if hilbert's space is sufficiently
big to contain all branches of the wave
function of our universe until now
what would it mean to have run out of
room when it eventually happens
say our calculations are wrong and the
universe runs out of room tomorrow
what would be our subjective experience
well i think that
the upper limit of the number of
splittings you can do of the wave
function of the universe
is tied to the approach to thermal
equilibrium
right the maximum number of splittings
happens in the maximum entropy state
that the universe can be in
so we're very confident that our
calculations are not wrong and we're not
going to run out of room tomorrow
because we're clearly not in the maximum
entropy state all of the
energy in the atoms that make up you and
me could be converted to photons and
that would dramatically
increase both the entropy of the
universe and the number of branches
of the wave function so we have a long
way to go
george sarbidza says how does zeno's
dichotomy paradox affect many worlds
theory
so xeno's dichotomy paradox is just the
classic one that if you want to
run a mile first you have to run half a
mile and then
half of the remaining distance so
another quarter of mile then another
half of that etc
and therefore you have to traverse an
infinite number of segments
and you can't do that so you can never
run a mile so
zeno's paradox has zero effect on many
worlds theory because
zeno's argument was wrong i hope that
everyone knows this
you can run a mile it is possible to run
a mile why
because it is possible to traverse an
infinite number of segments
and that we sort of figured this out in
the most correct way when we got
calculus
right right you sum an infinite series
and get a finite answer
so uh zeno you'll put his m put his
finger on
puzzles of the concept of continuity
but we resolve those puzzles they're no
longer puzzling to us
so and the same thing is true in many
worlds there's nothing special about
many worlds
dan inch says as a non-american the
concept of a legacy admission to
university seems very odd
and not in keeping with the goal of
excellence in learning or research
i understand that caltech does not adopt
this approach but wonder what your views
are about the practice
i'm not a super expert legacy admissions
for those who don't know
are when universities give preferences
to applicants
whose family you know whose parents or
whatever were graduates of the
university
it absolutely happens my impression is
it happens more than it should
but look you know why it happens because
families that sort of keep their
people their their parents and children
and grandchildren going to the same
university are more likely
to donate money to the university and
the thing about universities having
money is
it's not just used for lavish parties
for the university president
a lot of that money is used for research
and teaching
right so universities having money is
something i'm in favor of
um and how to best do that is a
difficult
question some you know there's a there's
a mixture of different strategies one
has
government grants private donations um
legacy admissions inspiring private
donations
tuition and fees and all these things so
i'm not against universities making
money because eventually
most of them are non-profit
organizations eventually that money goes
back into the university it's not just
used for frivolities having said that
you're right you would get a better
student body if you didn't have legacy
admissions
but you would also get less donations so
maybe you could give that student body
less of a good education that's the
trade-off you need to think about
arthur adelberg says does the kind of
timepiece being used affect whether it
would register time dilation
uh nope not at all every time piece
would effect be affected exactly the
same way
herb berkowitz says if general
relativity is the physics of the big
world and quantum mechanics is the
physics of the tiny world
where is the border between the two
where one applies on one side and the
other applies on the other side
well you know honestly it's completely
untrue
that quantum mechanics is the theory of
the tiny world and general relativity is
the theory of the big world
both quantum mechanics and gender
relativity are true on all scales
roughly speaking
the better way to say it is that the
intrinsically
general relativistic effects as opposed
to those that you could
describe using newtonian gravity only
become noticeable
in the big world in fact in a big world
where gravity is important
and the intrinsically quantum mechanical
effects as opposed to classical
mechanics only become noticeable in the
tiny world
but quantum mechanics has classical
mechanics as a limit it's always
true likewise general relativity is true
even in the room where you're sitting
right now
but there's no hard and fast boundary
where
the approximation of approximating
general relativity with newtonian
gravity
or approximating quantum mechanics with
newtonian mechanics
uh becomes more becomes correct or
incorrect
they just become more and more accurate
it's a smooth transition it's not a hard
dividing line
robert murley says i frequently heard it
said that the vacuum energy of the
universe is about 120
orders of magnitude lower than it should
be but i've never read why physicists
think that it should be that high could
you
oblige um yes i i did also talk about
this
in the biggest ideas videos maybe in the
one on renormalization
i'm not sure the point is that when you
take a classical theory and quantize it
there are quantities like the vacuum
energy that have a classical part
and then they are corrected by quantum
mechanics
so if you start with any classical
amount of cosmological constant
vacuum energy at all you can separately
calculate the corrections that you
expect from quantum mechanics
and it's those quantum corrections that
are 120 watts of magnitude
bigger than the actual cosmological
constant we observe
so it's possible that the right way to
think about it is
the classical contribution to the um
cosmological constant is exactly minus
the quantum correction except for the
tiny little bit that we observe
but no one sees why that should be the
case so it's just
really weird since we have no idea what
the
no expectation for what the classical
contribution should be
people say well the best guess for what
the
total cosmological constant should be is
approximately the quantum
part of it and that is in the effective
field theory approach
given by the planck scale it's a
dimensionless quantity and the planck
scale
energy density is 120 orders of
magnitude bigger than the observed
cosmos constant that's where the number
comes from
robert grenice says i've often heard you
say that the universe has no center how
is this possible
well um imagine a plane right a
two-dimensional plane
that the idea behind the mathematical
two-dimensional plane
is it literally goes off in all
directions
infinitely far there's no edge to it
right so because there's no edge there
is no center
to a plane you can put coordinates on it
where there the coordinates have a
center x equals 0 y
equals 0. but i could put coordinates
where the coordinates are different and
x equals 0 y equals 0
is a million light years away from that
there's no preferred
center at all in the two-dimensional
plane the universe as far as we know is
like that
it's three-dimensional three-spatial
dimensional but no matter what its
global geometry is there's no reason to
think it has an edge
the edge is either infinitely far away
or just doesn't exist at all so
therefore
analogously there's no center to it
rosemary felner says what do you think
are the most interesting frontiers for
the intersection between philosophy and
science
today well you know there are many but
there's two broad
classes there one broad class is
philosophy
about science and i think that if you
know this is what i was exposed to when
i was an undergraduate and i thought you
know it's cool but there's nothing i
want to do for a living
things like thomas kuhn paul firerob and
emery lockatosh karl popper for that
matter
um philosophers trying to understand how
science works
okay um i really don't know a lot i mean
that's still a very very active area and
i don't know a lot about
it there's another area of intersection
between philosophy and science which is
the foundations of science so like i
said before it's really just science
but it's done in a philosophical way in
a way that is more
amenable to being in a philosophy
department and obviously there's physics
questions there
like the measurement problem in quantum
mechanics the origin and nature of the
arrow of time
the anthropic principle right these are
all very interesting frontiers for the
intersection of philosophy and science
but it's also very very active in
biology and complex systems right
when do you call something an organism
what are the levels of selection on
which evolution happens
where does information seep into the
evolution of non-organic materials in
their
transformation into living beings right
these are philosophical questions
at the philosophy of biology so i just
think there's sort of too many
interesting frontiers to actually
address that in any simple way
phil johnston says i would love to know
your thoughts on if you think we're
living in a simulation
and what it would take to create a
universe size simulation is there
are there any clues at the quantum level
that could suggest an underlying code
structure
um so no i don't think we're living a
simulation i already talked about that
sorry phil is earlier in the
ama if you want to find it what would it
create to take one well it depends on
how good you want your simulation to be
many people have simulated uh universes
with a few particles in them on their
computers already
are there any clues at the quantum level
not that i know of i mean there's just
the laws of physics just like there are
at any other levels there's nothing
special about quantum mechanics that
make it look more
simulation-like than classical mechanics
ever did
maddox mcgray says if you had to choose
which do you think contributes most to
the dark matter puzzle
wimps axions or other light particles
machos
monde or something else so i think that
wimps are still the most likely
candidate weakly interacting massive
particles there's an ongoing mystery in
physics about
this energy and mass scale given to us
by the electroweak interactions
it's an energy scale about a hundred to
a thousand
gev a hundred to a thousand times the
mass of the proton that's the mass of
the higgs boson
uh close to the w and z bosons it's the
area where the top quark mass is
it would be very natural for a new
neutral particle to be found at that
energy scale that mass scale
with the weak interactions of particle
physics and if so would be a great dark
matter candidate
the only reason to be skeptical of that
is that we've looked and we haven't
found it yet
now it's hard to look and it depends on
exactly the details
of how the thing interacts these days
a successful model of dark matter would
have to have the dark matter candidate
wimp
interacting with ordinary matter via the
exchange of the higgs boson
and that gives a lot of freedom for how
big
that could be so it's kind of an open
question there but we've looked and
i i would say very very very roughly
we've ruled out half of the feasible
parameter space
so we could have found it already but
we're nowhere close to ruling it out in
any sense
axions are another great candidate other
light particles could constitute the
supermassive
sorry superfluid dark matter we talked
about earlier so those
those have risen a little bit and the
credence you should attach to them as
we've not found wimps
axions are also things we can search for
but they're harder to search for so we
haven't ruled out as much of the
parameter space
monchos are basically ruled out machos
are just collections of baryons but we
know there's good reasons that baryons
do not make up the dark matter
and mond is basically ruled out as an
exp
as a replacement for dark matter it
could be true that
dark matter that gravity is modified in
some interesting way
but things like the bullet cluster and
the cosmic microwave background
give very clear indications that there
is a gravitational pull
other than in the direction of where the
ordinary matter is so you need
something to be generating that
gravitational pull
gerald swann says in a recent podcast
you expressed some sympathy for jacques
derrida
what are some of his ideas that you
think are generally genuinely original
or that actually benefit from his
style of writing you know i'm by no
means a derrida
scholar so uh anything that i might
think is interesting in what he said i'm
not going to promise you
is genuinely original or wasn't said
better by someone else that's just not
something i'm qualified to talk about to
me
the interesting aspect of what derek is
on about
is this his insistence that it's not
nearly as easy as you think it is
to say something that is absolutely
clear and definitive
and univalent and impossible to wriggle
out of right
this is a linguistic statement but it
goes to ontological statements as well
that
this idea there are categories out there
in nature
that we can just definitively pin down
once and for all
sort of metaphysical absolutes is
something that i find it very healthy to
be skeptical about
i think there is a real world right i
think the world exists i think the
daredevil would agree with that would
have agreed with that
you know his brother was a very famous
physicist he was a fan of physics
himself deirdre
um but other than the world
existing you know our human scale world
the world of people and animals and
and concepts that we see in our everyday
world that's where daredale lived
because he was he was a philosopher and
literary critic
literary theorist so those kind of
categories are all approximate and
emergent
and i'm very much in favor of being
skeptical of their definitiveness and
that's what i take from him that's
obviously
a tiny tiny uh sliver of what he said
it's oversimplification but that if you
want to know why
uh i'm interested there it's it's that
and also i have to say that you know
physicists my my friends my my
colleagues my pals
just like almost any other set of
academics
can be really anti-intellectual
sometimes in the sense that
if they come across a different field of
academia
that they're not experts in and it seems
mysterious and they use different jargon
than they're used to
they just dismiss it and i think that uh
in in some sense i
stand up for daradah just because a lot
of other people who have no idea what
he's talking about
uh make fun of him without knowing what
they're talking about so
what i'm actually standing up for
secretly is not jacques dereda
in particular as much as it is the idea
that we should be extraordinarily
charitable and open-minded and humble
when it comes to people in one field of
academia
passing judgment on other fields of
academia
sad ahmed says as i've started using
twitter more recently i've realized that
there is no shortage of doctor
scientists and academics who question
the effectiveness of the lockdowns
school closings and the general
narrative around the pandemic
how do you generally approach people or
ideas that seem to contradict the
mainstream
views well you know it's a good question
it's an important question
because there are no views on which you
will find every person in the world even
every expert in the world in agreement
there are plenty of uh very famous
accomplished physicists
who are crackpots about one idea or
another there are funny people out there
who are flat earthers and you can find
them
on the internet right but they generally
are in the minority and also
you there are various ways of telling
that someone is a little bit less
credible you know look at what sources
they refer to
look at how open-minded they are uh look
at how much they spend time
ranting against the establishment
instead of actually providing evidence
for their claims etc
in the case of lockdown school school
closings etc
there are hard questions school closings
for example
not at all obvious when we should and
should not close the schools because
different populations spread the virus
differently
if you do close schools other things
happen to bring people into contact more
often and so that's a very difficult
sociological problem as well as
a virology problem but overall
the idea of getting vaccinated socially
distancing
closing down big public indoor events
these are all very well supported
wearing masks
very well supported by almost all of the
respectable part of the establishment
and so even if you are not comfortable
judging individuals on the basis of
their rhetoric or their evidence or
whatever
you can just look at what most people
who are smart are trying to say
and if you're not an expert yourself it
makes sense to go along with what most
of the experts are saying
until you have good reason not to
ferry says in the case of black holes at
what point does our current
understanding of physics break down
well you know we don't know okay we
haven't seen a black hole up close and
personal
nothing about the black holes that we've
observed either through electromagnetism
or through gravitational waves
is in conflict with any of our current
understanding of physics
we predict that of course our current
understanding of physics will break down
near the singularity
when curvature of space-time becomes
really really large that's that's a
pretty safe prediction it is also a
prediction that
if you want to get information out of
the black hole
then our current understanding of
physics has to break down earlier than
that because this is why the black hole
information loss puzzle is so puzzling
because
it's not enough to hide all of the
problem at the singularity
you need something that is outside our
current understanding of physics to be
going on
at the event horizon which is not close
to the singularity
but putting our finger precisely on what
that is
is hard to do you know listen to the
podcast they did with anetta engelhardt
we talk about the black hole information
loss puzzle and their modern ideas
have you know virtual euclidean
wormholes connecting
the matter that is outside the black
hole to the quantum state inside the
black hole also
that is in some sense a violation of our
current understanding of physics but on
the other hand
it fits in broadly speaking with the way
that we think about physics so it's not
completely
uh weird to us ross hastings says your
recent chat with alvi lope got me
thinking
about aliens and the fermi paradox what
if
dark matter was an alien thing could
dark matter be aliens
so roughly speaking probably not and
that is because we know a little bit
about dark matter dark matter doesn't
interact
with itself or with ordinary matter as
strongly as
ordinary matter interacts with itself
the reason why
you and i can exist is because we're
made of particles
protons and electrons and neutrons right
that interact with each other strongly
number one and number two they can lose
energy
by giving off photons so when two
particles bump into each other
they can cool down and stick to each
other by losing energy by giving off
photons
dark matter can't do that as far as we
know dark matter
has a distribution in space which is
almost exactly what you would expect if
dark matter didn't interact with itself
at all now i say almost exactly because
who knows and there are tiny little
anomalies that we have trouble
pinning down i actually wrote a paper
that proposed that dark matter interact
could interact with a dark
photon right that you have dark matter
particles and you have a
copy of the electromagnetic force that
only interacts with dark matter
the most naive version of that is
probably ruled out because you get dark
magnetic fields that would soak up a lot
of the energy and it doesn't quite fit
the data
but then what we propose at the end of
our paper and other people have since
gone on to
develop this idea in greater detail you
could have dark
atoms you could have two different
species of dark matter particles that
interacted with dark electromagnetism
and made bound states
and they would still have to interact
more weakly than ordinary matter but
maybe if something like that happened
you could get them to stick closely
enough to make dark molecules chemistry
aliens whatever they don't stick nearly
as well as ordinary matter does so it's
hard to do
but i don't think it's completely ruled
out
bill seltzer says might an extension of
quantum theory which enable the
derivation
of space and time also show that the
schrodinger equation is not fundamental
uh maybe completely possible you know
there like i said
earlier at least i alluded to it there
are formulations of quantum theory where
the schrodinger equation
is not the only part of quantum
evolution
objective collapse models say that the
schrodinger equation is usually true
but it's not always true so that's one
possibility
there are ideas stephen weinberg
proposed a theory where the schrodinger
equation is never
exactly true there are non-linear
corrections to it
but what you instantly discover is that
a lot goes wrong
as soon as you do that you can get
superluminal communication
or you get communication between
different branches of the wave function
there's all sorts of problems that
immediately crop up
so it's hard to modify the schrodinger
equation
but you could imagine doing it i would
just say since there's zero evidence we
have to
it is not a high priority thing for me
to start thinking about
kirk briggs says i've read through your
reading list on the pdf download from
the great courses plus
good plug for the advertiser there kirk
good for doing that and all of the books
were great except john bell's book was
over my head well sorry about that
i'd like to learn more about eternalism
and how it's mapped to space-time
um right i'm not sure if there's a great
book to learn about eternalism you know
i wrote a book about
time called from eternity to here where
i talk a little bit about eternalism
maybe that's
something you want but a book
specifically about eternalism i'm not
really aware of you know most
books about the philosophy of time are
either about relativity in one way or
the other
or they're about entropy in the arrow of
time you know once you make the
statement of eternalism
there's not that much to do with it all
moments of time are equally real
good what are you going to keep saying
about that i'm not quite sure uh
what there is to say but maybe there is
a book out there talking about i just
don't know about it
david lang says i know the universe is
probably not
anti-de-sitter but how do you how what
do you think are the chances of string
theory in a holographic cosmos leading
to
a correct formalism oh i still think
that string theory is the leading
candidate
for a good theory of quantum gravity out
there or at least
maybe some successor to string theory
you know
i am convinced not not convinced but i
am um
moved by the fact that string theory is
an enormously
fruitful theory you know most attempts
to go beyond known physics you know you
propose something new
and then you say okay well what does
that imply right you chug forward with
your equations and you try to
make it imply things and you get stuck
because
it doesn't really tell you that much
whereas string theory just
leads you to all these cool places like
the adsct correspondent so i'm
pro-string theory
tentatively in that sense um it's too
bad that we haven't had a lot of
great progress in recent years
connecting string theory to empirical
data and i do think that is a problem
um so i think but you know ads cft
i i think of as having a problematic
status
on the one hand it's a wonderful
playground to learn about quantum
gravity all the new stuff that i talked
about with netangleheart
was all inspired by ads cft you can ask
questions about quantum gravity and get
relatively well-defined
answers but it's not the real world and
the fact that it's not the real world
may or may not just be a technical
complication
right it may be that the right answer
for the real world
is inspired by ads cft and it's not that
far away from it
or it might be that to get the real
world you need to think in dramatically
different ways than what we do in ads
cft so i would
remain unconvinced by either arguments
on either side of that i think it's an
open question
ray walden says the recently published
paper testing the strong equivalence
principle detection of the external
field effect in rotationally sported
galaxies
um claims to have detected the external
field effect in over 150 galaxies
if this result can be verified and
reproduced independently will dark
matter no longer be required to explain
the observed rotation curves of spiral
galaxies
and is there any other reason to
continue looking for it
so i don't know anything about that
paper so i can't comment on it but what
i can tell you is this
if anyone claims that they can get rid
of dark matter
with a new kind of theory and you ask
them well what is the evidence that your
theory works
and the only thing they talk about are
the rotation curves of spiral galaxies
that person can be instantly dismissed
you do not need to take them seriously
the rotation curves of spiral galaxies
were the best evidence for dark matter
in the 1980s that was a long time ago
now those are not the best evidences for
dark matter
the cosmic microwave background large
scale structure baryon acoustic
oscillations
clusters of galaxies gravitational
lensing we have a whole suite of
evidence
for dark matter that goes way beyond the
spiral galaxies
so the very short response you should go
give to anyone who says anything like
that is
where is your prediction for the
perturbations in the microwave
background where is your power spectrum
if they can't do that
don't take them seriously riverside says
let me once again rephrase a question on
the moral implications of the many
worlds theory of quantum mechanics
so and then there's a long question so
riverside i'm sorry about this
i'm not going to let you once again
rephrase that question part of the rules
of the ama is we do not have ongoing
debates so if my original answer to the
question wasn't very good i apologize
for that
but i don't want the amas to be back and
forth to continue from month to month
sorry about that
yoram ramberg says it is my
understanding that the purpose of
empirical science is to find out
the truth about nature and how it works
this would suggest that progress in
science involves the discovery of facts
about nature
yet when talking about scientific
theories you're always using the
language of
invention why are you using the term
invention and not discovery
so yeah i started to answer this with a
previous answer but let me restate it
here
it's the difference between a fact about
the universe and a theory
about the universe right even if the
theory is true you know theory is
correct
like general relativity is correct in a
certain regime of applicability
we still invent the theory we don't
invent the facts that the theory
is judged by we take observations we
find out hopefully true facts about the
universe
but then putting those facts into a
structure that explains and accounts for
the facts is a human invention
like i said you do not bump into
theories lying on the beach or hiding in
a desk drawer you invent them in your
brain
and honestly that's what i think about
it i do not think about any of this
too strongly i do not think it matters
whether i call it intervention or
discovery honestly
douglas albrecht says if i understand
that the many worlds hypothesis flows
from an ontological starting point that
reality is the wave function and that's
all there is
what's the evidence for this being a
complete description of reality and why
are you so
certain of this assumption so i'm not
certain of this assumption i'm certainly
not certain about any theory of physics
whatsoever
certainly not many worlds i think it's
the most likely thing but certainty is
not
the right way to think about it the
evidence is that
every theory of quantum mechanics needs
wave functions
and i don't need anything else to fit
the data so that's all the evidence
that i need i'm going to look for the
simplest theory that fits the data and
many worlds is it
i could be wrong about that and if there
is more evidence that comes in
that is not accounted for by the wave
function being real i will certainly
consider it and change my mind
jonathan tucker says can you invite
david albert back on pretty sure i'd be
enthralled just listening to you to
discussing toasters
i have a bunch of people you know who
we've had on the podcast already who
certainly we've not exhausted all the
interesting things there is to talk
about
however so far there's also a whole
bunch of people that i haven't talked to
that have interesting things to say and
you know i'm
i'm open to changing my mind about this
but
my tentative belief is that i would
rather not have repeat guests
on mindscape like i said i agree there's
certainly many things
interesting to talk about um but
talking to new people is more
interesting to me than talking to people
i've already talked to
i'm probably going to regret saying that
because i'll probably have people on
later on
but you know that is my that is my
current feeling right now
boris petrovich says regarding
multiverse and many worlds hypotheses
which simply can't be in any way
experimentally verified
are they science or are they religions
uh nope they're science
i recommend that you read my paper or
beyond falsifiability to find out why
mark carc says i'd like to hear musings
as
if you were talking to a small child how
can the universe be either finite or
infinite neither makes any sense
so number one i'm not very good at
talking to small children about science
you know like my specialty
is talking to people who are a little
bit beyond the small
child stage and bringing them into an
even higher stage but i can try
um but this kind of question i i
i falter at because both of them make
perfect sense to me that the universe
could be finite or infinite that you
know the phrase
the statement neither makes sense just
kind of stops me
in my track i don't know what to do with
that why don't they make sense
um especially when you i would
have a little bit more sympathy or
understanding if you said how could the
universe be finite
or you said how could the universe be
infinite it doesn't make sense
but if you say it doesn't make sense
that it's finite or infinite then i
don't know what to do because those are
the only two options
finite means effectively that if you
walk off in some direction and you just
keep walking eventually
like it or not you will come back to
where you started
infinite means you start walking in some
direction and then even if you could
walk forever you would never come back
to where you started
that's the way i would try to explain it
dominique
de kalua says why does a photon reflect
from a mirror
under the same angle if it's re-emitted
by an angle
by an atom sorry why in this specific
direction
this is a good question it's a fun
question i've actually never thought
about this and it's a sort of a
condensed battery real world question
that we rarely get here
i don't encourage more questions along
these lines because
um uh i would not be able to answer most
of them but in this one i think i know
the answer
it's because you shouldn't think of the
reflection of a photon off a mirror
as a single photon particle
being absorbed by a single atom and then
being reflected
there are collective effects in the
mirrors that's why some
that's well let's put it this way i can
take the atoms that make up a mirror
and rearrange them into a knot mirror
right i could make it not polished etc
and then it would not reflect under the
same angle so it's clearly
not a feature of the individual atoms
it's a feature of the
structure into which those atoms are put
and what happens is and this is just a
cool fact about quantum mechanics
is that uh when you have a metal like a
really shiny metal for example i'll just
take that as an example
the electrons in a metal move
relatively freely from atom to atom
they're not tied
very strongly to individual atoms this
is why metals are good conductors of
electricity
and what happens very roughly to the
best of my very meager understanding
what an
when a photon or an electromagnetic wave
is incident on a reflective surface of a
metal
it's the collective response of a bunch
of electrons sort of
moving in one direction and then
bouncing back and then it's more it's
almost like
a trampoline where the electrons catch
the photon and then push it back
uh in the opposite direction not the
opposite direction but you know what i
mean
its transverse momentum is conserved and
its incident momentum is reflected
backwards
that's the best i can do for uh an
answer to that for more than that
you'd have to go to wikipedia or
something i guess steve
m says i seem to be at an impasse
i know my finger will not pass through
this table because fermions don't do
well moving other fermions
but wait those are only waves
perturbations and fields lots of fields
intersecting at my fingertip
why do i perceive the table's existence
when all those fermions are in
superpositions of being and not being
perturbations at this moment so i was
with you steve up until that last
sentence um the a real fermion particle
like a real electron
that is part of the table or whatever is
not in a superposition of being and not
being a perturbation
it is a perturbation it is a
superposition of different locations in
space but that just means it has a sort
of spread out wave function
but it exists there is some non-zero
feature
and and one way of thinking about this
is that fermion
number is conserved so you can change
fermions into bosons but only by
interacting them with anti-fermions so
if you have a
prot an electron and a positron
they can annihilate away into photons so
those two fermions can turn into bosons
but if you just have one electron it
cannot turn into
a collection of bosons it's fermioness
is real and it's there and it's not
going away and all the particles making
up your table
are fermions not anti-fermions so
they're all real
your table has a real conserved fermion
number
there's there's no trouble in
understanding why it would resist your
fingertip when you press into it
alan proxmeyer says entanglement is one
of the few topics that google and
youtube haven't given me the
understanding i want
even your greatest ideas videos leave me
with a lot of questions would you
consider doing another video on that
um so two answers to that one is i wrote
a book
about quantum mechanics and entanglement
is explained so youtube
and google are not the only places where
you could go for better information
sometimes you just need a deeper
understanding and neither
google or youtube are the place to go
books still have a place
in one's intellectual life i would say
um the other answer is
probably not going to do more videos on
anything i mean
i will do more videos in my life maybe
but i don't have any plans to either
extend
the biggest ideas series or to
start up a new series on something else
if i'm gonna do anything with that i
would rather turn the biggest ideas
video
into some kind of book themselves where
i could fit in more
details and do things even better you
know the thing about the biggest ideas
videos is they i said it and it was true
they were informal and off the cuff you
know i would look up numbers and things
like that but i did
very little research to do any of those
videos and as a result there are tiny
little mistakes that sneak in that i
tried to correct
in the comments and so forth but i hope
maybe i could do those in a book form
and get everything right the first time
all right ramon durman says if you can
imagine for a moment that you are
attached to a weather balloon
and that you're leaving earth's
atmosphere and drift further into space
beyond our system and the milky way
so this is a very good weather balloon
as you continue to drift in the same
direction you pass the galaxies furthest
away from
earth until you reach the very edge of
the universe what do you see
so even if ramon i let you have the
thought experiment of the weather
balloon
you would still never reach the edge of
the universe because there's no such
thing
as the edge of the universe at least
there is no
uh grown-up respectable theory of
cosmology according to which the
universe
has an edge so there's nothing to see
when you were there because it doesn't
exist
sorry about that all right it was a long
ama but we've reached the last question
michael lesniak gets the honors why do
the positively charged quarks have
double the electric charge as the
negative ones is this an indication we
don't have the entire picture
and the positive quarks are actually
composite particles composed of two each
perhaps
it's absolutely possible that we don't
have the entire picture
there are reasons for the charges of the
quarks to be related
to each other um dealing with anomaly
cancellations and other
tricky things in uh quantum field theory
and like we said before about the charge
of the electron if you
unify uh the forces of nature
then there are very good reasons users
there are predictions about the
charges of the of the quarks that fit
into this pattern
the idea that the positive quarks the up
quark for example plus two-thirds could
be a composite particle you know is one
that people have thought about
there are theories called prion theories
p-r-e-o-n
which you could look up on the internet
for that you're welcome to google it
um but they're not very uh
promising these days and the reason is
they make predictions the predictions
mostly are ruled out okay
there's no evidence that says that
positively charged quarks
are composite and there are predictions
for tiny little effects you should
be able to see if they were and we don't
see any of them
so probably that's just what it is you
know
the charge assignments of quarks and
electrons and all these things
they're complicated they're they're
nuanced they come
from a long series of symmetry breakings
and the higgs boson and things like that
the desire to sort of break them down to
saying well
this particle has twice the magnitude of
charge of the other one therefore it's
made of two
is almost never going to work right
things are more complicated than that
that doesn't mean you shouldn't look for
deeper explanations
but the only way to really have a chance
at getting a deep explanation that is on
the right track
is to learn a whole bunch of quantum
field theory and particle physics and
group theory
and then hope that you can come up with
a theory that turns out to be correct
that's what we're all hoping
isn't that what we're all hoping to come
up with a theory that turns out to be
correct
that would be a good thing to do in our
lives and with that
me and my voice have reached the end of
the ama and we're out of the questions
that i have in this file so
thanks for playing along see you next
month bye
[Music]
you